So, let's go ahead. I'm gonna go to the
screen and let's get into this
challenge. Um, so,
okay, here we go. Can y'all got Can you
see my screen? The 24hour
goat challenge. What is that challenge?
Can you find from the moment you see
this video? From the moment you see this
challenge, can you answer the challenge
within 24 hours? I believe that if what
you have is truth, it shouldn't take you
24 hours to find the answer to a
challenge to something that's
challenging what you what you believe.
All right. So, um what is the challenge?
In order to understand the challenge, we
need to see what our critics are saying.
So, let me go back. We're going to go
back to the screen. I'm going to lay the
challen the claim of our critics. And
here is the particular claim that I'm
looking at tonight. Number one, the
Lord's goat and the scapegoat make one
single sin offering. All right, the
Lord's goat and the scapegoat, they are
really h a a a type. They're both a type
of Jesus because they're just serving in
different functions, right? showing a
different aspect of the plan of
salvation. So they both make one single
sin offering. Okay, that's point number
one. Point number two, both goats were
required to show the forgiveness of sin
by the death of the Lord's goat and the
expeation of sin, the removal of sin
through the scapegoat. All right, so put
a one in the chat if you understand the
claim. thus far. Just go ahead and put
that one in the chat. This is the claim
of our critics. The scapegoat and the
lord's goat are not two different uh
don't represent two opposing symbols.
They are the same. They're different
coins or different sides of the same
coin.
Good evening. Thank you for being here,
especially if this is your first time
with us, Adventist or otherwise. What
you just heard is a clip from uh
Adventist critic of Christianity, Ivor
Meyers. And tonight, we're going to be
taking his 24-hour scapegoat challenge,
even though it's been more than 24
hours, because believe it or not,
everyone doesn't operate on his timeline
or at his beck and call.
Now, for those that may have seen his
video already, answering Adventism was
mentioned a couple of times. He played a
couple of clips to let people hear the
claims I've made regarding what the
scapegoat in Leviticus 16 represents.
And good on him for that. But we don't
do halfbaked turnarounds on this
platform. And truth does not have an
expiration date. I want to say that
again. Truth does not have an expiration
date. I put a lot of time into my
preparation for my responses and
presentations. So, if he thought he was
going to get this halfbaked immediate
response, he was sorely mistaken because
Ivor, since I know that you'll watch
this, not only am I going to take your
challenge, but we're also going to
critically examine your challenge and
its premises along with a number of
Adventist presuppositions and a lot of
source documentation.
This was the perfect opportunity by the
way and uh works as a case study for us
to talk a little bit about internal
versus external critiques, how to
analyze someone's arguments for
consistency and so on. Now, I want to
give credit where credit is due. He did
correctly present one of the claims that
Christians make about the day of
atonement sin offering generally
speaking.
And I emphasize that for a reason. We
will see why I say generally once we get
into it and I will explain why that is
uh partially a summation statement
meaning it is said as a result of a
number of other things in the text
besides simply Leviticus 16:5 and he
didn't mention those other things. When
Christians point to Leviticus 16:5 to
say that the scapegoat and the Lord's
goat function as one singular sin
offering yes the grammar of that text
does indeed say that. But there's more
in the text that proves that. And he did
not get into those things. At least not
in that intro clip. We will see if he
gets into it later on. But before we get
into that, as always,
if you like what we're doing here and
you feel called to support us, consider
becoming a YouTube member where you will
gain access to our growing library of
membersonly videos, including
membersonly live streams. The next of
which will be next week on Friday. Next
week on Friday, if you are a member,
make sure to head over to the community
page section on our channel where you
will see the membersonly post where we
are taking submissions for questions to
answer. It helps if you send those
through ahead of time. That way, I can
be more prepared than on the fly. Some
questions are fine for on the fly, but
others require some in-depth um
preparation to show up and give you the
best answer possible. So, if you are a
member, head over there and make sure
you get your question in. To uh I want
to give a thank you to all of our
members. Because of your generous
support, we are able to fulfill our
mission to the best of our ability to
equip as many Christians as possible to
reach as many Seventh Day Adventists as
possible. And I am super grateful for
all of you. So, thank you, thank you,
thank you. So, before we start listening
to Ivor, let me lay out a couple of
foundational clarifiers.
I have shown a quote on answering
Adventism numerous times before from
professor El Michael Morales and we're
going to look at that again because he
points out why the sin offering in
Leviticus 16 includes both the Lord's
goat and the scapegoat both functioning
as a single sin offering. Single sin
offering and it's more than just verse
5. It is a plethora of reasons. Notice
this is from his book, Who Shall Ascend
the Mountain? Which is a seminary
textbook on the book of Leviticus. I
highly, highly recommend this for all of
you theology nerds that always ask me
about books. Get this book. Quote, "The
scapegoat's role should be understood in
conjunction with that of the goat that
is sacrificed." As an elimination right,
the Aazil goat ritual is often probed in
isolation from a redactional and/or
comparative religion approach within the
context of Leviticus 16. However,
the right is fully integrated as part of
one complete ceremony associated
particularly with the young goat that is
sacrificed.
For example, while two rams are also
used on the day of atonement
as ascension offerings for the priestly
house and for Israel respectively, yet
these two animals are not brought
together in the same fashion as are the
two goats.
The text is quite careful to portray the
goats as a set.
The high priest takes them both from the
congregation of Israel, presents them
both together before Yahweh at the door
of the tent of meeting, and then cast
lots for them both.
The instructions for the high priest in
Leviticus 16:5, moreover, refer to both
goats together as a single purification
offering. To be sure, the expulsion
right is not an offering in the
technical sense.
I'm going to let that marinate for a
second.
To be sure, the expulsion right is not
an offering in the technical sense.
Nevertheless, in removing sin, the
scapegoat's function fits the precise
significance of sin as purification.
And combined with the blood manipulation
of the sacrificed goat completes the
picture of atonement.
Indeed, there is historical precedent
for understanding these goats to be
identical in appearance and chosen
expressly because of this likeness
as if it were one goat
accomplishing two different aspects of
atonement, purification and expeation,
cleansing from sin's pollution and the
removal of sin's guilt. Close quote. So
notice what Dr. Moris highlights
regarding the text.
Within the context of Leviticus 16, the
scapegoat right is fully integrated as
one single ceremony with the Lord's
goat. Part of this is evidenced in the
fact that the two rams that are used in
the day of atonement as ascension
offerings for the priest's house and for
the nation of Israel, they are not
brought together in the same fashion as
the Lord's goat and the scapegoat. The
text presents the goats as a set. Both
are taken from the congregation. Both
are presented before the Lord at the
door of the tent. Both have lots cast
over them. And both are referred to as a
singular sin offering, which is what
Leviticus 16:5 says.
He even recognizes that the scapegoat
isn't an offering in the technical
sense,
meaning it wasn't sacrificed.
But within the singular sin offering,
its function is significant to
purification in that combined with the
blood from the goat that was sacrificed,
both goats together, picture the
atonement. Now, there's an issue here
tonight and we'll get into this some and
we've looked at this I don't know how
many times before. This movement when
they use the word atonement mean the
investigative judgment as is stated in
their new supposed failsafe uh
scholastic work uh salvation contours of
avenous otiology.
But one pictures purification from sin
by way of paying the penalty for such.
The other pictures the removal or
expedation of that sin, removing its
guilt and stain.
But we also see that same sort of thing
two chapters prior in Leviticus 14 in
the ritual to cleanse leprosy. Notice
the similarity which evidence uh
evidences this isn't a one-off concept
within the Levitical law.
Leviticus 14:1-8
The Lord spoke to Moses, saying, "This
shall be the law of the lepous person
for the day of his cleansing.
He shall be brought to the priest, and
the priest shall go out of the camp, and
the priest shall look. Then if the case
of lepous disease is healed in the
lepous person, the priest shall command
them to take for him who is to be
cleansed two live clean birds and
cedarwood and scarlet yarn in hissip.
And the priest shall command them to
kill one of the birds in an earthnware
vessel over fresh water. He shall take
the liveb bird with the cedarwood and
the scarlet yarn and the hissup and dip
them and the liveb bird in the blood of
the bird that was killed over the fresh
water.
And he shall sprinkle it seven times on
him who is to be cleansed of the lepous
disease. Then he shall pronounce him
clean and shall let the living bird go
into the open field.
And he who is to be cleansed shall wash
his clothes and shave off all his hair
and bathe himself in water. and he shall
be clean and after that he may come into
the camp but live outside his tent seven
days and thus the reading of God's holy
word. So just like with the day of
atonement ceremony, a person that was
cleansed from leprosy was to take two
live clean birds along with cedarwood,
scarlet yarn, and hissup. They were to
then kill one of the birds over a vessel
of clean water and then take the live
bird along with the other elements and
dip them in the blood from the bird that
was killed. They were then to sprinkle
the lepous person seven times, pronounce
him to be clean, and then release it
into the field uh release the live bird
into the field that was dipped in the
blood. The living bird dipped in the
blood, picturing the disease being taken
away from the individual.
This is the same picture we have going
on two chapters later in Leviticus 16
with the day of atonement.
Leprosy is like representative of sin.
Two goats, single sin offering, both
functioning to complete the picture of
being cleansed for the sinner. One
paying the penalty, the other removing
the guilt and stain from their sight. We
will look at more of this chapter a
little bit later on. But the last thing
we need to establish before getting into
Mr. Meer's challenge is that Jesus is
the fulfillment of all of the laws,
sacrifices, and offerings. I cannot
emphasize this enough. I talk about this
periodically. We haven't gotten into it
too in depth on the channel before.
We've looked at a variety of them. But
the law required a large swath of
offerings and sacrifices. The grain
offering, sin offering, guilt offering,
wave offering, burnt offering, etc.
Jesus is the antitypical fulfillment of
all of them. When one understands this,
one also understands why Jesus is
pictured by the scapegoat which was part
of the sin offering. So let's look at a
couple of these, shall we?
Notice, for example, the burnt offering
which was around before national Israel
and the Levitical priesthood work.
Genesis 8 20-22.
This is after Noah gets off the ark.
Then Noah built an altar to the Lord and
took some of every clean animal and some
of every clean bird and offered burnt
offerings on the altar. And when the
Lord smelled the pleasing aroma,
the Lord said in his heart, "I will
never again curse the ground because of
man, for the intention of man's heart is
evil from his youth. Neither will I ever
again strike down every living creature
as I have done."
While the earth remains, sea time and
harvest, cold and heat, summer and
winter, day and night shall not cease.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
So after Noah and his family get off the
ark, the Lord commands Noah to build an
altar and take some of the clean animals
along with some of every clean bird and
offer them as a burnt offering on the
altar.
Noah does does this and that burnt
offering sends up a pleasing aroma to
the Lord
and upon doing so God's anger was
appeased.
So simply flooding the earth did not
appease his wrath. The flood was simply
a demonstration of that. But the burnt
offering sent up a pleasing aroma and
that appeased the Lord's anger and he
promised to then never flood the earth
again because of it.
Got it?
Well, now notice what Paul tells us in
Ephesians 5.
Therefore, be imitators of God as
beloved children and walk in love as
Christ loved us and gave himself up for
us, a fragrant offering and sacrifice to
God.
Ah,
the sacrifice of Christ was that
pleasing aroma that when offered up to
God, it appeased his wrath towards his
people. And it's why part of the promise
in the new covenant can be that he
remembers our sins no more. Jesus was
the true burnt offering and pleasing
aroma. Just like Isaiah 53 tells us, it
pleased the Lord to crush the sun. Paul
here understood the Old Testament. He's
not just using flowery language. Jesus
is the antypical burnt offering. And
there are many other places we could
look at to show this. Now, let's look at
the guilt offering. I mentioned Isaiah.
Isaiah 53:10-11.
Yet it was the will of the Lord to crush
him. He was he has put him to grief.
When his soul makes an offering for
guilt, he shall see his offspring. He
shall prolong his days. The will of the
Lord shall prosper in his hand. Out of
the anguish of his soul, he shall see
and be satisfied. By his knowledge shall
the righteous one, my servant, make many
to be accounted righteous, and he shall
bear their iniquities.
Thus the reading of God's holy word.
So this chapter is a prophecy about the
Lord's suffering servant who would come
redeem his people and suffer for them.
In that flow we are told it was the will
of God to crush him putting him to grief
and that he made an offering or what?
Guilt.
He bore our iniquities and like the
chapter says back uh uh in previous
verses,
this happened by way of God laying on
him the iniquity of us all. And it's on
account of this that his people can be
accounted righteous. Jesus is the true
guilt offering.
Let's look at one more. Jesus being the
antityypical wave offering.
We will see the wave offering mentioned
in Leviticus 14 later, but notice
Leviticus 23 9-14.
And the Lord spoke to Moses, saying,
"Speak to the people of Israel and say
to them, when you come into the land
that I give you and reap its harvest,
you shall bring the sheath of the first
fruits of your harvest to the priest,
and he shall wave the sheath before the
Lord, so that you may be accepted. On
the day after the Sabbath, the priest
shall wave it. And on the day when you
wave the sheath, you shall offer a male
lamb, a year old, without blemish, as a
burnt offering to the Lord. And the
grain offering with it shall be two
tenths of an ea of fine flour mixed with
oil, a food offering to the Lord with a
pleasing aroma. And the drink offering
with it shall be of wine, a fourth of a
hen. And you shall eat neither bread nor
grain, parched or fresh until the same
day until you've brought the offering of
your God. It is a statute forever
throughout your generations in all your
dwellings.
So, the feast of first fruits required
that the Israelites were to gather the
first crop of their labors, which were
the best of the best, and put them in a
sheath, which is a wrapping,
and then give them to the priest. The
priest is then to wave that sheath
before the Lord. And this was to take
place when?
the day after the Sabbath, which would
be the first day, the eighth day that
the chapter is already mentioned
numerous times in the chapter. Well,
that was Jesus in the resurrection. He
was the antitypical first fruits, Paul
tells us in 1 Corinthians 15, the first
fruits of the resurrection. He was the
first fruits of the new creation, which
is what the first fruits are also a
picture of, a picture of new creation.
So Jesus's body was put in a wrapping
like a sheath on the day before the
Sabbath just like the first fruits were
required to be. Then he remained in that
wrapping until the day after the Sabbath
where he then came out of them and
presented himself before God, waved
himself before God and was accepted.
So Jesus was both the priest and the
offering as we've looked at numerous
times before. And this is what the feast
of first uh first fruits along with the
wave offering was a picture of. We even
see the burnt offering and the pleasing
aroma mentioned once again. So the point
of all of this is to say Jesus fulfills
all of the laws, sacrifices, and
offerings and to ascribe any portion of
them to anyone else is to take away from
the perfect work of Christ.
With that in mind, let's begin listening
to the challenge. The argument basically
what they're saying
is that the Lord's goat and the
scapegoat represent two different
aspects
of the sacrifice of Christ and that it
could not be done with one goat.
It could not be done with one goat. So
you have to have two goats in order to
to show uh one the death of Christ and
then two the removal of sin.
All right. So that's the claim. That's
what we're going to be dealing with
tonight. And let's go ahead and go back
to the screen and I'm going to put up
here Levit Leviticus 16:5. This is the
text that is used. Uh the Bible says
here, "And he shall take of the
congregation of the children of Israel,
two kids of the goats for a sin
offering, and one ram for a burnt
offering." So the argument here once
again is see Leviticus 16:5 clearly
states
that both goats were for the sin
offering and so there should be no
argument because both of the goats are
making up this multi-dimensional aspect
of the sacrifice and experation of sin
and you needed two goats to do that. You
couldn't use one. Okay.
So he's correct like I said in the
general point that one of the claims
made is that both goats pictured a
singular action but that is the
summation statement Ivor
that's not all of the reasons for why
that summation statement is made meaning
we don't simply just point to Leviticus
165 and that's it
what Dr. Morales pointed out needs to be
reiterated throughout the entire
chapter,
the entire presentation in Leviticus 16.
The two goats are referred to as a set.
Both are taken from the congregation.
Both are presented before Yahweh. Lots
are cast over both of them with the
instructions in Leviticus 16:5 being
that they are to function as a singular
sin offering.
Ivor only highlights that single aspect,
not realizing that it's simply one
component of an entire flow and chain of
the narrative. And again, this is looked
at in conjunction with other ritual
aspects of the Levitical law, namely the
cleansing of leprosy, for example, like
we saw two chapters prior in Leviticus
14. Both doves functioned as a singular
cleansing ritual.
What were the biblical rules for a sin
offering? Let's go back to the screen.
offering? In other words, what
constitutes a sin offering? We need to
know that.
Um, and to to find this out, we just go
back to the Bible. And what we're going
to see is uh the sin offering is
mentioned uh in a couple places. So,
let's begin with Exodus 29:10.
Notice what it says. And thou shalt
cause a bulock to be brought before the
tabernacle of the congregation. And
Aaron and his son shall put their hands
upon the head of the bulock, and thou
shalt kill the bulock before the Lord by
the door of the tabernacle of the
congregation.
Verse 12, and thou shalt take of the
blood of the bullock, and put it upon
the horns of the altar with thy finger,
and pour all the blood beside the bottom
of the altar.
Reading on verse 14.
But the flesh of the bulock and his skin
and his dung shalt thou burn with fire
without the camp.
Without the camp. It is a put that put
those two words in the chat for me. It
is a sin offering. Okay. So based on
what we just read, the Bible tells us
what a sin offering is. Like if I were
to come up and say, "Hey, a sin offering
is when someone, you know, um, ties
their shoe and then jumps up and down
three times and then, you know, blah
blah blah." And I just make up a whole
bunch of crazy stuff and I say,
"Biblically, that's what a sin offering
is." You would know, "Yeah, you're
crazy." That's not what a sin offering
is. The Bible tells us what a sin
offering is. Now, that was Exodus 29,
but the Bible is going to tell us again,
and it's actually found in Leviticus
chapter 4,
where the heading of the chapter is
called the law of sin offering. So,
let's go there. Let's go back to the
screen. The law of sin offering. What
was this law of sin offering? Let's look
at this once again.
The law of sin offering, Leviticus
chapter 4, beginning with verse three.
If the priest that is anointed do sin
according to the sin of the people, then
let him bring for his sin, which he has
sinned, a young bulock without blemish
unto the Lord for a sin offering.
And he shall bring the bulock unto the
door of the tabernacle of the
congregation before the Lord, and shall
lay his hand upon the bulock's head, and
kill the bulock before the Lord. So
number one, a sin offering
required the animal to be killed. Verse
five, and the priest that is anointed
shall take of the bulock's blood and
bring it to the tabernacle of the
congregation. And the priest shall dip
his finger in the blood and sprinkle the
blood seven times before the Lord before
the veil of the sanctuary. So the blood
also had to be utilized to qualify
as a sin offering. Let's keep reading.
Verse 11. and the skin of the bulock and
all his flesh with his head and with his
legs and his inwards and his dung. Even
the whole bulock shall he carry forth
without the camp
without the camp unto a clean place
where the ashes are poured out and burn
him on the wood with fire. Where the
ashes are poured out shall he be burnt.
Okay. So, what we see here is that a sin
offering had to have there had to be
certain things done to qualify as a sin
offering. What were those things? Let's
once again go back to the screen. And
before I show I we we uh recap those
things, I just want you to note this
term without the camp. Nice. media, I
see you asking the question, what is
without the camp? Okay, so according to
Adam Clark's commentary on Leviticus 16
or Leviticus 4:12,
here's what he says regarding without
the camp. This was intended figuratively
to express the enormity of this sin and
the availableness of the atonement. The
sacrifice as having the sin of the
priest transferred from it from himself
to it by his confession and impositions
of hands
was become unclean and abominable and
was carried
carried
as it were out of God's sight. And thus
its own offensiveness was removed. Put
that word in the chat for me please.
removed
with the sin of the person in whose
behalf it was offered. So
the the the the burning of the body of
the very same animal that was slain to
forgive sin, the the fact that the body
was removed
from the temple, from the camp,
signified the removal
of sin.
Yes. and Ivor. Notice what the same Adam
Clark says when commenting on Leviticus
16 and the two goats
on the phrase, "And he shall take the
two goats." Quote, "It is allowed on all
hands that this ceremony taken in all
its parts
pointed out the Lord Jesus dying for our
sins and rising again for our
justification, being put to death in the
flesh, but quickened by the spirit. Two
goats are brought, one to be slain as a
sacrifice for sin and the other to have
the transgressions of the people
confessed over its head and then to be
sent away into the wilderness. The
animal by this act was represented as
bearing away or carrying off the sins of
the people. The two goats made only one
sacrifice, yet only one of them was
slain.
One animal could not point out both the
divine and human nature of Christ, nor
show both his death and resurrection.
For the goat that was killed could not
be made alive. The divine and human
natures in Christ were essential to the
grand expeation. Yet the human nature
alone suffered, for the divine nature
could not suffer. But its presence in
the human nature while agonizing unto
death stamped those agonies and the
consequent death with infinite merit.
The goat therefore that was slain
prefigured his human nature and its
death. The goat that escaped pointed out
his resurrection.
The one shows the atonement for sin as
the ground of justification.
the other Christ's victory and the total
removal of sin in the sanctification of
the soul.
Close quote.
Whoops.
Adam Clark didn't believe the scapegoat
represented Satan and recognized that
the text makes clear that both goats
functioned as a singular sin offering
despite only one of them dying.
Iver's use of Clark to try and bolster
the SDA position creates contradictions
in Clark's own theology because notice
what he did. The claim was essentially
made that sin offerings according to the
Bible always had to die. He then
appealed to Adam Clark, a Methodist
commentator, to try and add legitimacy
to his claim. Yet, the same Adam Clark
says that both goats in Leviticus 16
functioned as a singular sin offering
despite only one of them being slain. He
believed, and I don't necessarily agree
with him on this in terms of the the
picturing the death and the
resurrection. I think that's
interesting. I'd need to study that
more, but this is just the facts. He
believed both goats pictured the two
natures of Christ, both his human and
divine. One showing the penalty for sin
and the other the removal of sin.
So, according to Ivormey, Clark was
apparently correct and reliable on sin
offerings in Leviticus 4, but completely
wrong when talking about the sin
offering in chapter 16.
No. If you're going to try and apply to
him to support your claim regarding sin
offerings, then your use of him
shouldn't create contradictions within
his own belief.
Besides the faulty appeal to Clark, the
fundamental error here is that none of
the texts that he read state that a sin
offering can never include a second
animal which doesn't die alongside the
one that does.
The point being, Adam Clark's theology
is not a friend to this movement,
despite their ardent insistence that
they're firmly in the Methodist
tradition. I can assure you of this.
Adam Clark did not have a great
controversy worldview. Adam Clark did
not believe in the SDA church's novel
seven steps through the sanctuary model
of redemption, of which the scapegoat is
only a sliver of.
And the reason this issue is such a hot
topic in Adventism is because they have
to be correct on this for the entire
framework to remain intact.
If this is false, their entire system
crumbles.
Then he cited Leviticus 4 to try and
support the idea that sin offerings
required blood to be used in the temple.
Folks, pay very a very close attention
here.
For those that have been riding with us
for a while, you already know where this
is going. Ivor specifically cited from
one of the various requirements for
various sin offerings and has now turned
a specific requirement into a universal
one.
Leviticus 4 gives various requirements
for various sin offerings and not all of
them were involved with taking the blood
into the temple.
Did you notice Leviticus 4:3 when he had
it on the screen?
Leviticus 4 1-6.
And the Lord spoke to Moses, saying,
"Speak to the people of Israel, saying,
'If anyone sins unintentionally
in any of the Lord's commandments about
things not to be done, and does any one
of them, if it is the anointed priest
who sins,
thus bringing guilt on the people, then
he shall offer for the sin that he has
committed a bull for the herd without
blemish to the Lord for a sin offering.
He shall bring the bull to the entrance
of the tent of meeting before the Lord
and lay his hand on the head of the bull
and kill the bull before the Lord. And
the anointed priest shall take some of
the blood of the bull and bring it into
the tent of meeting.
And the priest shall dip his finger in
the blood and sprinkle part of the blood
seven times before the Lord in front of
the veil of the sanctuary. And thus the
reading of God's holy word.
Ivor cited from a specific requirement
for when who sins?
The priest. Verse three, when the priest
sinned, these were the instructions to
be carried out. And he cites this
turning it into a universal for all sin
offerings to claim that the blood of all
sin offerings was to be used in the
temple. He will reiterate this again
later, by the way.
Except if you actually read the chapter,
you'll see there are instances where sin
offerings were carried out and the blood
was not used in the temple. Notice
Leviticus 4, same chapter 22- 26.
When a leader sins
doing unintentionally any of all the
things that that by the commandments of
the Lord his God ought not to be done
and realizes his guilt or the sin which
he has committed is made known to him,
he shall bring as his offering a goat, a
male without blemish,
and shall lay his hand on the head of
the goat and kill it in the place where
they kill the burnt offering before the
Lord.
It is a sin offering.
Then the priest shall take of the blood,
some of the blood of the sin offering
with his finger and put it on the horns
of the altar of burnt offering, and pour
out the rest of the blood at the base of
the altar of burnt offering. And all its
fat he shall burn on the altar like the
fat of the sacrifice of peace offerings.
So the priest shall make atonement for
him for his sin, and he shall be
forgiven.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
So this is just one example. But when
the leader sinned unintentionally, not
the priest, not the individual penitent
Israelite, the leader was to bring a
blemishfree, notice both the instances,
blemish free, he was to bring a
blemishfree goat to the priest as a sin
offering. And he was to lay his hands on
the head of the goat and kill it in the
place of the burnt offering before
Yahweh. Then the priest would take some
of the blood from that sin offering and
put it on the horns of the altar of
burnt offering. then dump out the rest
of the blood at the base of the altar,
burning all the fat on the altar. This
then made atonement for the leader and
he was forgiven. All of this took place
outside of the sanctuary.
At the beginning, we looked at the
cleansing of leprosy in Leviticus 14.
Notice later in that chapter,
Leviticus 14 11-20.
You guys better buckle up tonight. We
are just getting started, folks.
Get out your notepad. Start taking
notes.
It is about to get.
And the priest who cleanses him shall
set the man who is to be cleansed and
these things before the Lord at the
entrance of the tent of meeting
where.
And the priest shall take one of the
male lambs and offer it for a guilt
offering along with the log of oil and
wave them for a wave offering before the
Lord. And he shall kill the lamb in the
place where they kill the sin offering
and the burnt offering in the place of
the sanctuary. For the guilt offering,
like the sin offering, belongs to the
priest. It is most holy.
The priest shall take some of the blood
of the guilt offering, and the priest
shall put it on the lobe of the right
ear of him who is to be cleansed, and on
the thumb of his right hand, and on the
big toe of his right foot. Then the
priest shall take some of the log of
oil, and pour it into the palm of his
own left hand, and dip his right finger
in the oil that is in his left hand, and
sprinkle some oil with his finger seven
times before the Lord. And some of the
oil that remains in his hand, the priest
shall put on the lobe of the right ear
of him who is to be cleansed. And on the
thumb of his right hand, and on the big
toe of his right foot, on top of the
blood of the guilt offering.
And the rest of the oil that is in the
priest's hand, he shall put on the head
of him who is to be cleansed. Then the
priest shall make atonement for him
before the Lord. The priest shall offer
the sin offering to make atonement for
him who is to be cleansed from his
uncleanness. And afterward he shall kill
the burnt offering.
And the priest shall offer the burnt
offering and the grain offering on the
altar. Thus the priest shall make
atonement for him and he shall be clean.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
So after the lepous person was cleansed
from their leprosy,
the priest still had to follow through
with a ceremony of a guilt offering, a
wave offering, a burnt offering, a grain
offering, and a sin offering.
The tail end of the end of the ceremony
involved the priest making atonement
before the Lord, offering the sin
offering for the individual that had
been cleansed of leprosy, followed by
afterward killing the burnt offering.
And all of this was to take place where?
At the entrance of the tent of meeting.
Not inside the sanctuary. Outside. Which
again proves no, not all sin offerings
were required to have their blood taken
into the sanctuary. And there are more
we could look at, but this suffices for
that point.
Again folks, it is vital to understand
that Jesus is the fulfillment of all of
the laws, sacrifices, and offerings in
one. And yes, the scapegoat is a part of
sacrifices and offerings.
It's not just some standalone thing off
to the side. And then everything else is
a sin offering, guilt offering, burnt
offering, etc.
He's the true guilt offering, the wave
offering, the sin offering, the burnt
offering, the grain offering, etc. The
Advenist position wants to steal some of
Jesus's work and fulfillment and credit
it to Satan.
So Ivormeers's Ivormeer's premises are
badly flawed and his challenge is
predicated upon them being correct.
What this shows is that there is nuance
to some of these things. It's not always
universally the same,
which is why you can have sin offerings
that involved two animals, but only one
of them was sacrificed. It also shows
why it's dangerous to handle the Bible
this way, the way that Adventists do,
which involves bringing their already
preconceived ideas to the text to then
try and hunt around to find things they
think they think support their already
preconceived beliefs.
They do not come to the text and derive
out of it what the author is intending
to communicate and then simply um you
know a agree with that.
But also notice,
what did we read in Leviticus 4:23?
Ivor is trying to make the case that the
scapegoat wasn't a part of the singular
sin offering. Yet, it very clearly was.
Sin offerings had to be without blemish.
Is Satan without blemish?
No. But Jesus is. Now again, they're
going to try and get around this by
essentially saying, "Well, no, the
scapegoat wasn't a part of the sin
offering."
And be prepared for some of the crazy
gymnastics you're going to get from SDAs
on this. I've heard all sorts of stuff.
I mean, I've heard stuff like, "Well,
Satan originally was blemish free before
he fell, so therefore he qualifies." And
other crazy ideas like that. All of this
to say nothing he has said thus far
proves that Satan is the scapegoat. Nor
does it present any problems for the
Christian position. He did however shoot
himself in the foot multiple times.
But we need to verify this. Let's just
go back. We're going to go back to the
screen
and let's look at what Matthew Henry
says about this very verse. Matthew
Henry's commentary. When God pardons
sin, he quite abolishes it, casts it
behind his back. the iniquity of Judah
shall be sought for and not found. So,
here's another Bible scholar who is
saying, yes, when the when the animal
was taken out of the temple and the body
burned, it signified the removal
of sin.
Not just the forgiveness of it, but the
removal. Okay.
once again appealing to another
commentator regarding sin offerings when
the individual being appealed to doesn't
even agree with your claims about
Leviticus 16. Ivor, again, notice,
folks.
This is one of my spiritual ancestors.
This is Matthew Henry's conclusion of
the chapter in his commentary on
Leviticus 16 where he says, "Let us see
what there was of gospel in all of
this." So he's concluding like any good
Bible student, he seeks to show how one
can see Jesus foreshadowed in Leviticus
16. What does he say? Here are typified
two great gospel privileges of the
remission of sin and access to God. Both
which we owe to the mediation of our
Lord Jesus.
Here then let us see
one the expeation of guilt which Christ
made for us. He is himself both the
maker and the matter of the atonement.
For he is one, the priest, the high
priest that makes reconciliation for the
sins of the people. Hebrews 21:17. He
and only he
is par negotio fit for the work and
worthy of the honor. He is appointed by
the father to do it. Who sanctified him
and sent him into the world for this
purpose that God might in him reconcile
the world to himself. He undertook it
and for our sakes sanctified himself and
set himself apart for it. John 17:19.
Close quote.
Ah. So, Matthew Henry believed Jesus
represented both goats.
Which means that he clearly didn't agree
with the point Ivor is trying to make,
which is that sin offerings exclusively
and always died.
Again, none of the texts that he has
cited thus far state that sin offerings
can never include a second animal
alongside the one that dies such that
both function as a singular offering.
Nothing that he has cited has proven
this yet.
On top of that, the same Matthew Henry
recognized something I've pointed out
numerous times on this platform, which
is that Jesus functioned as a high
priest while on earth. Contrary to the
SDA church's claim that Jesus was
inaugurated as a priest at his
ascension, Henry rightly recognizes that
Hebrews 21:17 as well as elsewhere
refutes this. Jesus functioned as both
the sacrifice and the priest that
offered the sacrifice up to God. The SDA
church agrees that the day of atonement
sacrifice took place at Calvary.
And Ivor was just going on about the
law's requirements for sin offerings.
Well, the law required that the day of
atonement sacrifice be offered up by
who?
just anyone that came along and wanted
to do so. No, exclusively the high
priest. Jesus was that great high priest
that offered up himself as the
sacrifice, which encompassed all of the
laws, sacrifices, and offerings, not
just the sin offering.
And Hebrews 9:26 makes it clear that sin
was put away at the cross. And if you
understand the Old Testament sacrificial
system, you will understand what the
author is getting at when he mentions
this. Let's quickly look at Hebrews 9
because I want to make sure those who
haven't seen this see it.
So in Hebrews 9, the author is
continuing his compare and contrast
between Jesus and the Levitical priests,
explaining why Jesus is superior. In
chapters 7-10, he's explaining the
superiority of Jesus's Malkisedcian
priesthood over and against the Levites,
as well as the new covenant over and
against the old Mosaic covenant. Hebrews
9:23-26.
Thus it was necessary for the copies of
the heavenly things to be purified with
these rights, but the heavenly sacrif or
the heavenly things themselves with
better sacrifices
plural than these. For Christ has
entered not into holy places made with
hands like a building, which are copies
of the true things, but into heaven
itself, now to appear in the presence of
God on our behalf. Nor was it to offer
himself repeatedly as the high priest
enters the holy places every year with
blood not his own. For then he would
have had to have suffered repeatedly
since the foundation of the world. But
as it is, he has appeared once for all
at the end of the ages to put away sin
by the sacrifice of himself.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
So something to notice
verse 23 says sacrifices
plural.
The single sacrifice of Christ
functioned as a multiplicity of
sacrifices. And this is what I was
saying about Jesus being more than
simply the sin offering. He was also the
antityypical guilt offering, burnt
offering, etc. And instead of entering
into an architectural building like the
earthly priests which were simply a
shadow of the true thing, Jesus entered
into heaven itself to appear in the
presence of God. But catch this.
This is pivotal, folks. You have to ask
yourself, why is the author bringing
this stuff up? Why is he saying this?
Before the Levitical priest could enter
into the presence of God, what did he
have to do?
He had to make a sacrifice for himself.
Leviticus 16:6 says that Aaron had to
offer a bull as a sin offering for
himself and he shall make atonement for
himself and for his house. Since Aaron
and the Levites were sinners, they had
to make atonement for their own sins
before they could enter into God's
presence inside the temple.
Well, Jesus wasn't a sinner,
which means that part of the ritual must
not have pointed to Jesus, right?
Because it wasn't just the two goats
that are mentioned in a sin offering in
Leviticus 16, but also the bull for the
priest. But since Jesus wasn't a sinner
and the bull for a sin offering was to
be offered for the priest on behalf of
his sins, the bull must have not pointed
to Jesus. Right.
wrong. What does Peter tell us in his
first epistle?
1 Peter 2:24, Jesus bore our sins in his
body on the tree. Isaiah says the same
thing. We heard it earlier. Isaiah 53,
God the Father laid upon Christ our
iniquities. Same thing by Paul in 2
Corinthians 5. He made him who knew no
sin to be sin so that we might become
the righteousness of God. Which means
that just like the Levitical priest that
was a sinladen criminal in God's sight
and had to have sin removed
before he could enter into God's
presence.
So too Jesus having our sins placed on
him had to put that sin away before he
could enter into heaven into the
presence of God.
That's the author's point in Hebrews
9:26 when he says that Jesus put sin
away at the cross. And he goes on to say
that this is why when he returns, it's
not to deal with sin, but to save his
people. The work of dealing with sin was
done at Calvary, not in heaven in a
building starting in 1844, almost 2,000
years after the cross.
Unlike the Levitical priest who did this
ritual, entered in, completed the day of
atonement ritual, and then exited only
to have the process again the following
year, Jesus performed the work once and
for all, entered into the presence of
God once and for all to sit down on his
throne, showing that the work of dealing
with sin is finished. A point the author
of Hebrews has made multiple times up to
this point in the book.
And this is also what Matthew Henry
taught and believed on this, by the way.
Like I said, Matthew Henry is one of my
spiritual ancestors. I can assure you
his theology is not a friend to
Adventism, folks. I can assure you of
this. It's like when I saw him citing
Henry, I'm thinking to myself, dude, you
are out of your depths. You are fishing.
You're fishing.
All of this rich theology refutes this
movement's claim that Satan is the
scapegoat and that Jesus is up in heaven
still dealing with sin in the
investigative judgment to eventually
transfer it on to Satan who will then
cleanse the universe of sin.
The simple fact that it was put away at
Calvary refutes their entire framework.
We are still waiting to hear a challenge
to accept or something presented that
poses problems for the position that I
put forth or those that hold to the same
one.
So to recap, to recap, let's look at our
overview,
a sin offering required three things.
Number one, the animal was to be killed.
Number two, the blood was to be used in
the temple in the in the tabernacle. And
number three, the dead body was taken
outside of the camp
to signify
the removal
of sin. Put a eight in the chat if you
are already like, I see the challenge
already. I haven't stated the challenge
yet. I'm just saying put a eight in the
chat if you're already like, oh snap.
You know, like we used to say in the old
days.
Yeah, I know where this is going and I
knew where it was going on my first
watch through before even hearing the
rest of the video because Adventists
have been making the same arguments and
claims for 180 years as if we haven't
heard them 5 million times. What he's
trying to put forth is that the
scapegoat can't be a part of the sin
offering because scripture allegedly
teaches that all sin offerings
universally had to have those three
things happen to them. They had to be
killed, their body used in the
sanctuary, and their body taken outside
of the camp. And since that stuff
doesn't happen to the scapegoat, it
can't therefore be a part of the sin
offering. Again, his overview and
premises are flawed.
Regarding point two,
like I said, and we saw, there are sin
offerings either in Leviticus 4, a mere
10 verses after where you tried citing
that didn't involve the blood being
taken into the sanctuary,
which proves that not all sin offerings
were universally the same. nor can they
all be looked at and treated the exact
same way. This is horrible handling of
the Bible.
It's a very narrowed again, they're just
looking for stuff to to try and support
their already preconceived belief.
His other premises simply beg the
question. For those that don't know what
that fallacy is, it's when you assume
what needs proven.
He has just assumed what he's failed to
prove because he didn't prove that
universally speaking, all sin offerings
can never include a second animal that
accompanies the one that was slain but
isn't killed itself.
Where did any of the texts say that he
read that every sin offering universally
can only include one single animal,
never a second one?
And if that isn't proven, 3 is
nullified, de facto, because the body
being taken outside of the camp has to
do with being killed.
So all three of his premises are flawed
here.
But I want to highlight something else.
Even if we granted 0.1 for example,
they believe in annihilationism and that
Satan will eventually be blotted from
existence and killed, which would mean
that Satan is killed as the scapegoat in
their model.
So if Satan can be the scapegoat and he
eventually gets killed, then it's
inconsistent for Ivor to claim that
Jesus can't be the scapegoat because the
scapegoat wasn't killed, only the Lord's
goat was.
which is precisely one of the arguments
they try and put forth to say Jesus
can't be the scapegoat as he's trying to
build his case for. Just an interesting
observation there.
But that's where he's trying to go with
this and present a deductive argument to
prove that the scapegoat can't possibly
be be a part of the sin offering.
Despite the text verbatim saying two
goats were to be taken as a pair for a
singular sin offering,
they have to argue against the plain
thus sayeth the Lord. Despite people
like Ted Wilson telling us that the only
accepted hermeneutic in the Seventh
Adventist Church is the historical
grammatical method of interpretation and
a plain thus sayeth the Lord. Right?
Unless it foils the entire system, then
it is Olympic level mental gymnastics
and scripture twisting.
Okay.
So, let's go back and now we're going to
check out what did this what did these
bodies outside of the camp signify? Does
the New Testament say anything about the
bodies that were burned outside the
camp? Let's go back to the screen and
let's look at Hebrews 13:1.
Note what the Bible says here. for the
bodies of those beasts whose blood is
brought into the sanctuary
by the high priest for sin
for sin are burned without the camp.
Wherefore Jesus also that he might
sanctify the people with his own blood
suffered without the gate. Let us go
therefore unto him without the camp
bearing
his reproach. How interesting.
In the Old Testament
the the sin offering was a part of the
daily services.
So, so what the daily services were
teaching
was something very simple. Through the
death of the animal,
forgiveness of sin was attained. Through
the blood of the animal,
there was
it was also a symbol of forgiveness. But
when that same animal's body was removed
and put outside the camp, it signified
the removal of sin.
So my question right now is did one
animal symbolize both forgiveness and
the removal of sin according to what
we've just read according to Hebrews
chapter 13 11-13. Did one animal signify
both the the death of Christ as well as
the expeation or the removal of sin? Yes
or no? I'm talking about in the daily
services.
Yes or no?
The sin offering.
Yeah. Simple. The answer is no. And this
is where they try and make the scapegoat
be about responsibility, which is
entirely foreign to Leviticus 16. A few
weeks ago, we saw the same thing with
Steven Boore. He just kept saying it
over and over and over. The scapegoat
represents responsibility.
Responsibility. As if he says it, you
know, five million times. That just
makes it true.
Despite Iver's three earlier premises
being flawed, he now adds another one to
the pile.
Nothing that he said about Hebrews 13 is
a problem for Christians if you actually
know what's going on contextually.
If you actually utilize the historical
grammatical method of interpretation,
which again Ted Wilson tells us is the
only approved interpretive method within
the SDA church.
But what was he trying to claim about
Hebrews 13?
Well, he brought up his slide with a
couple of verses and underneath it, it
said the problem. Except there is no
problem for Christians with this text.
But then he said in the Old Testament,
the sin offering was a part of the daily
services. So his argument is that in the
Old Testament daily service, a person
was forgiven and their sin was removed
all through the blood sacrifice of a
single animal. Therefore, in the once a
year day of atonement service, the same
thing is true. And the single sacrificed
animal both brings forgiveness of sins
as well as expedates them away. Thus,
the scapegoat doesn't function as
expeation for sin. That's the argument
in Hebrews 13 is supposed to support
this. Except no,
the point of the author in Hebrews 13
has nothing to do with proving that
Jesus was only the Lord's goat and that
the single goat alone was the sin
offering that functioned as both
forgiveness and expeation.
The point being made there is that like
the animals that were taken outside of
the camp and burned, so Christ also
suffered outside the camp. And the call,
because there was a call in that verse,
an exhortation for believers.
The call is for us to follow after him,
bearing our cross, which comes at a
great cost. Bearing the same sort of
reproach he did by bearing his own cross
outside the camp. And I'm going to prove
that in a moment because he isn't going
to put forth what he thinks it is. Uh uh
because he's going to put forth what he
thinks it's saying. Sorry.
But the application he tries to make
with this text doesn't work if you
actually understand the context.
But Ivor, you presented another problem
for your system.
Again, folks, we're doing a lot of
internal critiques tonight.
It's when you assume the belief system
that you're criticizing, not your own,
and then point out internal holes within
that framework based on claims that
they're making.
He's trying to argue that the Lord's
goat both paid the penalty for sin and
died as well as expeated sins.
Except experation isn't transference to
another location. Expeation is entire
removal, blotting out. They're gone.
It's why one of the promises of the new
covenant is that God remembers the sins
of his people no more. Jeremiah 31,
Hebrews 8:12, which cites Jeremiah 31.
Their system doesn't teach this. They
teach that Calvary was only where the
atoning sacrifice took place, just like
the Lord's goat.
Notice
Ellen White, Christ in his sanctuary,
page 180.
The work of the investigative judgment
and the blotting out of sins
is to be accomplished before the second
advent of the Lord. Since the dead are
to be judged out of the things written
in the books, it is impossible that the
sins of men should be blotted out until
after the judgment at which their cases
are to be investigated. But the apostle
Peter distinctly states that the sins of
believers will be blotted out when the
times of refreshing shall come from the
presence of the Lord and he shall send
Jesus Christ. Acts 3:19 and 20. When the
investigative judgment closes, Christ
will come and his reward will be with
him to give to every man as his work
shall be. Close quote.
Forgiveness and the removal of sin is
what allegedly is happening in the
investigative judgment where Jesus began
cleansing the heavenly sanctuary of sin
that he transferred there. They don't
teach that sin was removed in the
sacrifice of Christ.
There was allegedly an 1813-year
gap between the antityypical Day of
Atonement sacrifice and the process of
it being removed starting. It's not even
finished yet. You're talking 2,000 years
removed from the sacrifice. And Jesus is
currently working on expeation which
will involve the transference of sin to
Satan who will ultimately expedate it.
Ellen White also twisted St. Peter's
words in her proof texting to try and
support this. Folks, notice Acts 3.
Acts 3 11-21.
While he clung to Peter and John, we'll
get to who that is. All the people
utterly astounded ran together to them
in the portico called Solomon's.
And when Peter saw it, he addressed the
people. Men of Israel, why do you wonder
at this? And why do you stare at us as
though by our own power or piety we've
made him walk?
The God of Abraham, the God of Isaac,
and the God of Jacob, the God of our
fathers, glorified his servant Jesus,
whom you delivered over and denied in
the presence of Pilate when he had
decided to release him.
But you denied the holy and righteous
one and asked for a murderer to be
granted to you. And you killed the
author of life whom God raised from the
dead. To this we are witnesses. And his
name by faith in his name
has made this man strong whom you see
and know. And the faith that is through
Jesus has given the man this perfect
health in the presence of you all.
And now brothers,
I know that you acted in ignorance
as did also your rulers.
But what God foretold by the mouth of
all the prophets
that is Christ would suffer i.e. Isaiah
53 he thus fulfilled.
Repent therefore and turn back that your
sins may be blotted out that times of
refreshing may come from the presence of
the Lord and that he may send the Christ
anointed for you Jesus whom heaven must
receive until the time for restoring all
the things about which God spoke by the
mouth of his holy prophets long ago and
thus the reading of God's holy word.
So Peter begins preaching to Jews who
were astonished at the apostles, namely
Peter and John, because in the previous
verses they had just healed a man.
So the Jewish people chase after them
and find them in Solomon's portico where
Peter begins preaching and he
rhetorically asks them why they're
amazed because this power with which
they healed was not of their own. He
then transitions to saying it's the God
of our fathers that did this and that
God glorified his son Jesus Christ who
they had handed over to Pilate to be
killed. He then proceeds to rebuke them
by saying in their rejection of Jesus
they had the author of life killed.
But it was faith in Jesus that gave the
lame man his health not the apostles.
He then transitions to an exhortation
for them to repent and be saved. Verse
17, he says,"I know you did this in your
ignorance. You handed over the author of
life to be murdered and and accepted a
murderer in his place. I know you did
this in ignorance, but it actually
fulfilled what God had foretold through
the prophets in the Old Testament
scriptures." These scriptures you're
familiar with. They foretold that Jesus
would come as the Lord's suffering
servant. We then get to verse 19 where
Ellen White tried to proof text and
support the investigative judgment.
Peter says,"I know you killed Jesus in
ignorance, but repent and be converted
that your sins might be blotted out that
times of refreshing might come upon you
right now. You fellow Israelites
standing before me, repent right now and
have redemption applied such that your
sins are blotted out right now.
have redemption applied to you that the
the the author of life that you had
killed accomplished. He accomplished the
redemption of all things. He didn't
apply that redemption universally though
when it happened. When you believe that
accomplished redemption is applied to
you, I'm getting ready to do a stream
here in the future. We're going to get
into redemption accomplished versus
redemption applied. This is such a a a
an important subject that not even just
within the context of Adventism.
Christians have to understand
the Christian faith is like anemic on
this right now. You have to understand
the difference between redemption
accomplished and redemption applied.
But Peter's giving them an exhortation.
find relief for your sin
for having the the author of life
crucified. He can forgive you.
Nothing to do with almost 2,000 years
into the future. Jesus will begin
blotting out your sins after he conducts
a meticulous investigation to see if
when you made your profession of faith,
you were truly genuine, etc. Folks, I'm
telling you, this woman did not know how
to execute the Bible to save her life.
The Bible is just a grabag for this
lady.
And Desmond Ford tried bringing this up
to the SDA church back when his massive
work on Daniel 8:14 and the
investigative judgment was published,
but they wouldn't have it.
And this was coming from someone that
tried to remain in fellowship with the
organization and still felt that the
idea of a pre-advent investigative
judgment along with the great
controversy wasn't wrong. Notice
I'm not a massive Dez Ford fan,
but even he
quote the whole argument about the sins
of believers, though forgiven still
requiring it to be blotted out, falls
short of the teaching of scripture. The
text we use, referring to Adventists in
support, Acts 3:19, teaches nothing of
the sort.
One only needs to compare Acts 3:19,
Acts 238, and Psalm 51:1-2 to see this.
Note also that the Greek in Acts 3:19
does not teach a blotting out of sin
during the falling of the latter reign,
but as a precursor.
Thus, as Acts 238 promised the gift of
the Holy Spirit to all who come to
Christ as penitence, so does Acts 3:19.
That and no more. Not one of the texts
that we use for the investigative
judgment has any validity in that regard
and will not stand up to what?
Grammatical historical exugesus.
Close quote. Ah,
that is an honest man, folks. I don't
care what you think about Dez Ford. I
know Adventists hate Dez Ford. They've
been brainwashed to think that he was
this horrible apostate.
Just wow.
But that is exactly spot on. Which is
why I constantly point out that when
people like Ted Wilson say the only
approved hermeneutic within Adventism is
the historical grammatical method, it is
only lip service.
Dez Ford was honest enough to recognize
this and say it and they tarnished his
name and booted him from the movement
for it amongst a host of other honest
recognitions that he made. But back to
Christ in his sanctuary so people can
see her claim isn't a one-off. A couple
pages later, quote, "At the time
appointed for the judgment, the close of
the 2300 days in 1844 began the work of
investigation and blotting out of sins.
All who have ever taken upon themselves
the name of Christ must pass its
searching scrutiny. Both the living and
the dead are to be judged out of these
things which were written in the books
according to their works." Close quote.
So that is to say that Jesus uh paid the
penalty for sin and removed it as only
the Lord's goat, not both the Lord's
goat and the scapegoat.
Does that jive with what I said that
Jesus paid the penalty for sin and
removed it as only the Lord's goat?
No, experation is not transference to
another building or or to another
location.
So to say that Jesus paid the penalty
for sin, get this folks,
to say that Jesus paid the penalty for
sin and removed it as only the Lord's
goat, not both the Lord's goat and the
scapegoat.
Then in his model, he also has to say
that when Jesus was killed and his body
taken outside the camp, sin wasn't
removed until almost 2,000 years later
where it still hasn't been removed, but
it's being worked on.
They claim forgiveness can only take
place in the sanctuary or rather the the
actual expeation of the the the the
work.
Like Dez Ford pointed out, you can have
forgiveness, but the actual blotting out
of your sins takes place up in the
sanctuary.
Again, Ellen White, patriarchs and
prophets, but also in Christ in his
sanctuary. We've looked at this about
200 times.
The blood of Christ while it was to
release the repentant sinner from the
condemnation of the law was not to
cancel the sin. It would stand on record
in the sanctuary until the final
atonement.
So in the type the blood of the sin
offering removed the sin from the
penitent but it rested in the sanctuary
until the day of atonement. Close quote.
No, they don't teach that sin was
removed or expedated when Jesus's body
was taken outside the camp and he was
killed. Christians do because we can
recognize that the antityypical day of
atonement was the actual day of the
crucifixion, not some huge gap from the
sacrifice taking place and then a
decadesl long process beginning, you
know, 1813 years later.
Just like on the typical day of
atonement in Leviticus, the antityypical
day of atonement was also a single day
where Jesus functioned as the high
priest offering up himself as the
ultimate fulfillment of all of the laws,
sacrifices, and offerings with the
penalty for sin paid, the sin removed,
and Jesus declaring it is finished. End
of story. And again, like I said, I know
what Adventists are going to say. If
Jesus removed sin, then why is it still
present in our world? And that's a fair
question. And it's why I said earlier,
if that's you, you need to study
redemption accomplished
versus redemption applied.
Redemption accomplished
I will save getting into that for that
presentation.
But even in their model, folks, they
have Satan functioning as expeation. So
I don't know why Ivor is trying to make
this sort of argumentation.
Satan will be the one that eventually
has sin placed on him and he will then
be annihilated and that's how sin is
ultimately removed in their model.
Notice what the footnotes of the
fundamental beliefs book says regarding
this. This is the SDA church's
experation of their own or or expation.
This is the SDA church's exposition of
their own 28 fundamental beliefs. And
this is in the footnotes on the chapter
regarding the investigative judgment and
the sanctuary. Quote, "If Azazil
represents Satan, how can scripture
connect him with the atonement?"
As the high priest after having cleansed
the sanctuary placed the sins of Azazil,
who was forever removed from God's
people, so Christ after having cleansed
the heavenly sanctuary, will place the
confessed and forgiven sins of his
people on Satan, who will then be
forever removed from the saved.
Now begins the SDA Bible commentary
which is coming from Ellen White. How
fitting that the closing act of the
drama of God's dealings with sin should
be a returning upon the head of Satan of
all the sin and guilt that issuing from
him originally once brought such tragedy
to the lives of those now freed of sin
by Christ's atoning blood. Thus the
cycle is completed. The drama ended.
Only when Satan, the instigator of all
sin, is finally removed, can it truly be
said that sin is forever blotted out
from God's of God's universe. In this
accommodated sense,
accommodated sense, we may understand
that the scapegoat has a part in the
atonement. Leviticus 16:10.
with the righteous saved, the wicked cut
off, and Satan no more. Then, not till
then will the universe be in a state of
perfect harmony as it was originally
before sin entered. Close quote.
So, did you get that? SDA scholarship
knows they have to account for Leviticus
16:10 saying that the scapegoat is a
part of the atonement.
So if they are saying the scapegoat
represents Satan, then they are saying
Satan is a part of the atonement, which
would mean that Jesus and Satan together
accomplish a person being made right
with God because that's what atonement
is.
So they try and defend their position by
saying, well, it's only in an
accommodating sense.
Only in an accommodating sense.
Jesus uses Satan to place the sins on
him since he was the originator of sin
and is responsible for such. So that's
how Satan can be part of the atonement.
And like I said earlier, this is where
they try and weasel in that the
scapegoat, well, it pictured
responsibility,
even though the text says nothing of the
sort.
He's used by Jesus to truly remove sin
from the universe. Meaning Jesus and
Satan together accomplish the atonement.
Utter blasphemy.
But make sure you caught the
inconsistency for what Ivor said. He
tried claiming that Jesus being taken
outside the camp represented both the
penalty for sin being paid and the
removal of sin
to try and say, well, so the scapegoat
has to represent something else because
expeation was a part of what the Lord go
Lord's goat did. It died and expeated
the sins. So therefore, the scapegoat
has to represent something else. Yet in
their model, sin was not removed at
Calvary. It was transferred to heaven
and it allegedly stands on record in
books up in a building in heaven where
an angel is documenting down every
individual sins for Jesus to then look
over those books in the investigative
judgment. Okay, we will get into without
the camp in a moment.
Okay,
good. Good. We're on the same page. We
see that according to the daily
services,
the same animal
who died for the sin offering, his blood
was also used and his body taken outside
the camp, which Paul says, hey guys, the
body's being taken out of the camp is a
symbol of Jesus. But please note
that it was a body that was taken out of
the out of the camp, not a living thing.
Did y'all catch that?
In the sin sacrifice, the thing taken
out of the camp was dead.
It died.
That was the whole thing about the sin
offering. It was dead. It wasn't taken
alive out of the camp. It was dead out
of the camp. So, if I would just do a
study on what is a sin offering, let's
just look at the Bible. What is a sin
offering? Well, oh, the Bible tells us
this is what a sin offering is. And
anything that does not fit in that
category of a sin offering cannot be a
sin offering.
Right? And I already refuted your entire
premise by showing how you didn't
examine widely enough to see that
certain aspects of different sin
offerings had different nuances.
He has yet to prove that the law
anywhere states or required that all sin
offerings universally could only ever
include one single animal.
One doesn't even need to proceed any
further because the entire foundation
for the, you know, for this is badly
broken.
But let's keep listening because now
he's going to put forth what he thinks
the phrase he bore the reproach means in
Hebrews 13:13. And this is why I wanted
to wait on talking about without the
camp.
Okay,
let's go back to the screen. And what
does it mean that Jesus bore the
reproach? Let's look at s few verses.
We're going to look at Psalm 69:7.
The Bible says here, "Because for thy
sake I have borne reproach." I have
borne who bore reproach.
Who bore the reproach?
Because for thy sake I have borne
reproach. Shame has covered my face.
Y'all understand that this is a
reference to Jesus.
who bore
our
shame.
Isaiah 50:6, I gave my back to the
smiders and my cheeks to them that
plucked off the hair. I hid not my face
from shame and spitting. I need y'all to
understand that the word reproach is
synonymous with shame.
Hebrews 12:2, "Looking unto Jesus, the
author and finisher of our faith, who
for the joy that was set before him,
endured the cross,
the place where he died outside the gate
of Jerusalem, who endured the cross,
despising the shame. He endured shame on
our behalf."
How interesting.
Isaiah 53:4,
"Surely
he has borne our griefs
and carried our sorrows.
Yet we did esteem him stricken, smitten
of God and afflicted, not escaped of
God, not set free, but smitten of God
and afflicted, meaning killed."
He was wounded for our transgression.
Was the scapegoat wounded? No. No, the
scapegoat was not Was the scapegoat
afflicted? No. The scapegoat was not
afflicted. He was wounded for our
transgression. He was bruised for our
nick. Was the scapegoat bruised? No. No.
No. The chastisement of our peace was
upon him. And with his stripes did the
scapegoat get in his stripes. We are
healed. All we like sheep have gone
astray. We have turned everyone to his
own way. And the Lord has laid on him
the iniquity of us all. Beloved,
the the daily services well amplified,
well well symbolized
forgiveness of sin
as well as the blood having the power to
remove the sin.
Our
sins were put upon Jesus and he bears
them.
That's right. He He bears what should
have been what what we should have
borne.
He does that. That's what he does for
us. That's why it's called a sin
offering.
the goat, the animal, the bulock
died. Its blood taken into the temple,
taken into the tabernacle, and its body
removed outside the camp. Okay,
so notice he didn't actually deal with
the phrase bear the uh reproach other
than to say Jesus bore reproach. The
scapegoat didn't, so therefore Jesus
isn't the scapegoat.
but no actual exogesis of the text. You
know, utilizing the historical
grammatical method and explaining what
is even going on in Hebrews 13. Jumping
to Isaiah and the psalter isn't how you
exedute Hebrews 13.
It's one thing to make a a parallel
reference as you are executing the text,
but not just citing a a cornucopia of
proof text to then just say, see, so
therefore,
now I'll show why this application of
the text is badly flawed in a moment,
but first he rhetorically asked if the
scapegoat wasn't wounded,
and since it wasn't, it can't be
representative of Jesus either. If Jesus
is both the Lord's goat
and the scapegoat because the Day of
Atonement sin offering involved two
animals, not just one, then this is a
situation of a both and, not an
eitheror.
Yes, Isaiah is describing the Lord's
suffering servant. I mentioned this
earlier when I was talking about Hebrews
9:26,
but what's fascinating about this
is he didn't catch how Isaiah uh uh uh
15:16 backfires on his position.
Ivor, where in Leviticus 16 does it say
that the first goat, the Lord's goat,
had sins placed on it? Not Isaiah 15:16.
Sorry, 53.
Isaiah 53:6.
Sorry, there's a lot of numbers here
going on. I I crossed some wires there.
He didn't even catch how Isaiah 53:6
backfires on his position
because where in Leviticus Ivor in
Leviticus 16, where does it say that the
first goat, the Lord's goat, had sin
placed on it?
It doesn't.
And he's going to try and show this
later, so I'm not going to get ahead of
myself.
But only the scapegoat had sin placed on
it. Leviticus 16:21-22.
Yet Isaiah 53 says that sin was placed
on him, which is something that was
exclusive to the scapegoat.
Isaiah 53 literally has what both goats
did being said of Jesus, being stricken
and bruised for sin while also having
sin placed upon him.
In fact, notice at the end of Leviticus
16 where it talks about the animals
being taken outside the camp, the phrase
Ivor keeps referring to.
Leviticus 16:23-27.
Then Aaron shall come into the tent of
meeting and shall take off the linen
garments that he put on when he went
into the holy place and shall leave them
there. And he shall bathe his body in
water in a holy place and put on his
garments and come out and offer his
burnt offering and the burnt offering of
the people and make atonement for
himself and for the people. And when the
fat of the sin offering he shall burn on
the altar, and he who lets the goat go
to Aazil shall wash his clothes and
bathe his body in water, and afterward
he may come into the camp.
and the bull for the sin offering and
the goat for the sin offering whose
blood was brought in to make atonement
in the holy place shall be carried
outside the camp. Their skin and their
flesh and their dung shall be burned up
with fire.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
And here's why this gets even worse for
his position.
Hebrews 13 and Leviticus 16 both say
that the body of the Lord's goat was to
be taken outside of the camp along with
the bull that was to be used for the
priest and they were to be what?
Burned.
Uh-oh.
So that has to mean Jesus wasn't the sin
offering either by Ivor's own standard
of argumentation
because Jesus's body wasn't literally
burned outside of the camp.
Yet the day of atonement sin offering
was the Lord's goat was.
Since Jesus wasn't literally burned
outside the camp, I guess that means he
can't be the Lord's goat either then.
This is an example of an internal
critique, by the way.
But folks, this is the problem with
trying to look for 100% exactness on
every single parallel.
It's an abuse of typology and it causes
the Adventist position to try and prove
too much, which is what Ivor ended up
doing there.
No one is claiming the scapegoat was
bruised or killed.
It was a part of the single sin
offering.
It was still a part of the single sin
offering though. And you haven't proven
anything thus far to the contrary. Jesus
is that single sin offering. The picture
being painted for Israel in the day of
atonement sin offering is the penalty
and wages of sin along with their sin
being taken away. Jesus does both. A
mere animal could not be killed,
bruised, etc. And then also picture for
them their sin being taken away. That
animal was dead. That's why two were
needed. Jesus is superior to mere
animals. And he is able to be all of the
laws, sacrifices, and offerings in one.
and complete all of what those types and
shadows pictured. All of them pointing
to him. He was both bruised for our
iniquities and taken away
with sin taken away as John the Baptist
heralded in John 1, behold the lamb of
God that takes away the sin of the
world.
And and if you're an Adventist that
tries to use this silly argument when
that's brought up that right, a lamb,
not a goat. Okay, so he's not the Lord's
goat either.
The law allowed for certain
circumstances, folks, for law, for lambs
and goats to be interchanged.
It's really that simple, though. Jesus
is both.
Now, executing Hebrews 13:13. For
starters, Ivor read a couple of verses
that are imploring Christians to go and
do something themselves, but is busy
focusing on trying to make it about
whether or not the scapegoat was a part
of the Day of Atonement singular sin
offering.
That's not at all what is in focus in
this paricopy.
Verse 13 says, "Let us go therefore unto
him outside the camp bearing his
reproach." Why is the author saying
this? Again, I always ask this question.
Why is he saying this? That's what
matters.
That's what will determine if I's usage
of this passage is sound.
Hebrews is a sermon that's being
preached to Jewish converts to the
faith.
These folks were tempted to go back to
the types and shadows of the old and
forsake Christ in the process because to
do such is to trample underfoot the
blood of Christ.
So he covers in chapter 6 and chapter 10
clearly they were tempted to go back to
the temple and start doing animal
sacrifices again. Think about how hard
it would have been, folks, for a Jewish
convert who their whole life it's just
been blood and gore just slaughtering
animals after one one after another over
and over and then to be told that's all
done. The the one sacrifice of Christ. I
I mean that would have
the temptation would have still been
there of I got to keep doing this.
There's no way it can just be one. The
author is then informing them and
educating them that no, Christ is the
end of all of that. He's the fulfillment
of all of it. Literally all of it.
And like I said, he warns them
specifically with regards to sacrifices
in chapter 6 and 10 that to do so, to go
back to those things is to trample
underfoot the blood of Christ because
there are no more sacrifices for sins.
That's actually what's being said by
that text, by the way, not what the
Adventist church tries to say is being
said. But nevertheless, by the time he
gets to what we call chapter 13, because
chapter and verse divisions are an
addition in the 1500s, he's already laid
out a bunch of truths using Old
Testament imagery that the original
hearer would have been very familiar
with. This verse then, verse 13, is an
exhortation in the benediction of the
sermon that the author includes amongst
a number of other final exhortations
before signing off. Notice from the
beginning,
this is the final chapter. He's giving
the final sign off here. We're going to
read Hebrews 13 1-16. Yes, I know we're
doing a lot of reading, but that's what
this requires, folks. not this little
cherry-picking here and there. You can
sometimes make points that way. I
understand that. But when you're going
to try and make some application like
he's doing, you better make sure that
your application is consistent with an
exogetical walkthrough of the text.
Let brotherly love continue. Do not
neglect to show hospitality to
strangers, for thereby some have
entertained angels unawares. Remember
those who were in prison as though in
prison with them and those who are
mistreated since you also are in the
body. Let marriage be held in honor
among all and let the marriage bed be
undefiled. For God will judge the
sexually immoral and adulterous. Keep
your life free from love of money and be
content with what you have. For he has
said, "I will never leave you nor
forsake you." So we can confidently say,
"The Lord is my helper. I will not fear.
What can man do to me? Remember your
leaders,
those who spoke to you the word of God.
Consider the outcome of their way of
life and imitate their faith. Jesus
Christ is the same yesterday, today, and
forever.
Do not be led away by diverse and
strange teachings, for it is good for
the heart to be strengthened by grace,
not by foods which have have not
benefited those devoted to them.
We have an altar from which those who
serve the tent have no right to eat.
For the bodies of those animals whose
blood is brought into the holy places by
the high priest as a sacrifice for sin
are burned outside the camp.
So Jesus also suffered outside the gate
in order to sanctify the people through
his own blood. Therefore, so because he
did that, let us go to him outside the
camp and bear the reproach he endured.
For here we have no lasting city, but we
seek the city that is to come
through him. Then let us continually
offer up a sacrifice of praise to God,
that is the fruit of lips that
acknowledge his name. Do not neglect to
do good and to share what you have for
such sacrifices are pleasing to God. And
thus the reading of God's holy word.
So it's a number of final reminders
being made to encourage the hearer of
the sermon they just heard. The
conclusion of the presentation, continue
to love one another as the body of
Christ. Be hospitable. remember those
that are being persecuted for the faith
that have been thrown into prison,
instructions about marriage, not loving
money, and so on. In that list, we get
the exhortation in verses 11 through13,
which is what Ivor referenced. With
regards to verse 13, we must ask four
things.
One, what is the camp?
Two, how are we to go forth from it?
Three, how do we go to him?
And four, in what way?
He didn't address any of this. He tried
focusing on the parallels the author's
making between Jesus and the sacrificed
animals of old. But why is the author
making this parallel? That is what
matters. Ivor never explained this.
The author is consistent with his theme
throughout the whole sermon, comparing
and contrasting what makes Jesus
superior. But by answering those four
points, we can understand and assess
what is being said by these verses that
he cited. And we're going to utilize a
little bit of John Owen from the shelf
behind me back there
to help us out. And I always preface
before citing Owen when it comes to the
book of Hebrews. Folks, you can like or
not like the Puritans. I don't really
care.
But Owen's work on the book of Hebrews
is the gold standard.
It is the largest volume of work. And
the man's Greek prowess was at the next
level.
To get your masters of divinity in that
day, in that with that crowd, you didn't
just have to know Greek. You had to be
able to debate in Greek. You had to use
Greek.
And that's why I often reference him
when discussing Hebrews because I do
actually care about the historical
grammatical method, not just paying lip
service to it. And John Owen uses it
properly. Pay very close attention to
how he answers these four questions
regarding verse 13.
Quote, one, the apostle in all this
epistle hath respect unto the original
institution of the Jewish church state
and worship in the wilderness.
Therefore, he confines his discourse to
the tabernacle and the services of it
without any mention of the temple or the
city wherein it was built, though all
that he speaks be equally applicable
unto them. Now the camp in the
wilderness was that space of ground
which was taken up by the tents of the
people as they were regularly pitched
about the tabernacle.
Out of this compass the bodies of the
beasts for the sin offerings were
carried and burned.
Here unto afterwards answered the city
of Jerusalem as is evident in this
place.
For whereas in the foregoing verse
Christ is said to suffer without the
gate,
here he is said to be without the camp.
These being all one and the same as to
the purpose of the apostle.
Now the camp in the city was the seat of
all the political and religious converts
of the church to the Jews.
To be in the camp is to have a right
unto all the privileges and advantages
of the commonwealth of Israel and the
whole divine service of the tabernacle.
For if any lost that right by any means,
though but for a season, they were
removed out of the camp.
See Leviticus 13:46 24:23, Numbers 52
and 12:15.
So Owen starts by rightly pointing out
that the Jewish hearer would have
understood what being in the camp meant.
Remember they are being exhorted by the
author to leave the camp and go to where
Jesus is.
Yet within the camp is where they
understood all of their privileges were.
The camp was the seat of political and
religious convocation of the people of
God.
So already there is an exhortation to
give something up for Christ. Owen
continues
two.
How were the Hebrews on the account of
the sacrifice of Christ and the
sanctification of the people by his own
blood to go out of this camp?
For it is all one whether we read the
word go out of the camp unto him or go
forth unto him without the camp, namely
who there suffered.
Now is not uh now it is not a local
departure out of the city where is
intended in the first place. Though I am
apt to think from the next verse that
the apostle had some respect also there
unto for the season was now approaching
wherein they were soed depart out of the
city before its final destruction.
This the apostle may now prepare them
for. But that which principally is
intended is a moral and religious going
forth from the camp. Close quote. So
basically Owen says here he thinks the
book of Hebrews was written before AD70
when the temple was destroyed and
Jerusalem had you know the the the
Jewish Roman wars.
He thinks that because well if it had
already been destroyed the temptation to
go back to the old way wouldn't have
been there anymore.
So he basically points out that there's
also a seemingly imminent call to the
original audience to get out of the
camp, the city before the destruction of
the temple comes. So he basically points
that out to say in conjunction with what
else I'm saying, that would have been an
immediate application that also could
have been valid to the original
audience. But he continues,
"There was nothing that these Hebrews
did more value and more tenaciously
adhere unto that political and religious
interest in the commonwealth of Israel.
They could not understand how all the
glorious privileges granted of old unto
that church and people should so cease,
as they had ought to forsake them."
Here on the most continued in their
unbelief of the gospel, many would have
mixed the doctrine of it with their old
ceremonies, and the best of them found
no small difficulty in their
renunciation.
But the apostle shows them
that by the suffering of Christ without
the gate or camp,
this they were called unto.
Close quote.
So get that, friend.
Like Christ who suffered, we are to also
suffer for him.
It would have been comfortable and easy
for a Jewish convert to return to the
types and shadows versus remain being a
Christian, which was at that time
basically signing up for a death
sentence.
Before the author closes off the book,
he gives them this final exhortation to
cling to Christ. Don't return to the
shadows like Christ who bore reproach
and shame and and mockery and scorn by
dying a grueling humiliating death on a
cross. So you need to follow after him
and also face scorn, ridicule, and even
potentially death if the Lord so calls
you to it.
Owen continues drilling in on the text.
Three, they were thus to go forth unto
him. He went forth at the gate and
suffered. And we must go forth after him
and unto him. And it denotes one, a
relinquishment of all the privileges of
the camp and the city for his sake.
Leave them and go to him. Two, a closing
by faith with his sacrifice and
sanctification thereby in opposition
unto all the sacrifices of the law.
Three, the owning of him under all that
reproach and contempt which were cast
upon him in his suffering without the
gate, not being ashamed of his cross.
And four, the bet ourselves unto him in
his office as king, priest, and prophet
of the church and unto our acceptance
with God and in his worship as the
apostle directs. Verse 15, the sum of
all
is that we must leave all to go forth
unto crucified unto a crucified Christ.
Close quote.
So back in Hebrews 7:1, when the author
first began explaining Jesus being after
the order of Melkisedc and not the
Levites, he states that Melkisedc was a
priest, king, simultaneous role.
In passing, as I've shown numerous
times, this is a serious problem for the
SDA church's model and does indeed cause
problems for their claims about the
scapegoat. They have Jesus ceasing to be
a priest at a point in the future when
the investigative judgment ceases.
Contrary to the same Hebrews 7 telling
us that Jesus is a priest forever,
as was foretold of the psalter in Psalm
110, and it's cited by the author of
Hebrews multiple times. I've addressed
this problem in depth on our website uh
in other videos, so you can go check
that out. But also, next week, we're
doing our first ultimate biblical
decimation, and that is starting with
the investigative judgment, where we
will look at that one in particular.
But that also poses serious problems for
their sanctuary claims, which their
belief about the scapegoat is only a
small part of. But it's all a chain, and
they need it all for their capital T
theory to work. But all in all, no.
Hebrews 13:13 does not prove the point
that Ivor tried to prove because
unfortunately he didn't track with the
author and understand why the parallel
was being made. He abused the parallel
to try and make it appear like it
supports his point when it doesn't.
It doesn't. To reiterate, the point of
the author has nothing to do with
proving that Jesus was only the Lord's
goat and that single goat alone was the
sin offering that functioned as
picturing both forgiveness and
expeation.
The point being made is that like the
animals that were taken outside the camp
and burned, so Christ also suffered
outside the camp. And the call is for us
to follow after him, bearing our cross,
which comes at a great cost, bearing the
same sort of reproach he did by bearing
our cross like he did outside the camp.
But on top of that, Ivor, the same
author told you back in chapter nine
that the sin offering again put sin away
at the cross.
And I already explained what this is
talking about. But I've done an
exogetical walkthrough of that as well
using the historical grammatical method.
It's not talking about sin being
transferred to a sanctuary building in
heaven to then be stored and
investigated to eventually be
transferred again onto Satan.
The SDA church appeals to Leviticus 4,
specifically the verses that Ivor read
earlier to try and prove this. And we've
dealt with that uh a hundred times at
this point. There's an article
addressing it on our website. Blood
wasn't taken into the sanctuary during
the daily ministration for individual
penitent Israelites.
Remember, Ivor read the requirements for
when the priest sinned.
That was one of the occasions when the
blood was taken into the sanctuary.
The other is in the verses right after
that when the entire community of
Israelites sinned unintentionally.
But only on those two occasions was
blood taken into the sanctuary. Aside
from the day of atonement,
the SDA church needs the text to say
that for individual penitent Israelites
in the daily ministry, blood was taken
in uh when the individual sinner
came and was penitent. But it doesn't
because blood wasn't taken into the
sanctuary on those occasions.
But that's what they claimed the new
covenant was pictured to be. Jesus would
enter the real temple, the heavenly one,
and take his blood into there to begin
cleansing the sanctuary like on the day
of atonement. And since their parallels
break down in this area as well, so does
their teaching on the scapegoat. If
there was no blood transferred to heaven
to then be transferred to Satan, that's
the key, to then be transferred to
Satan. Jesus did go up and present his
once-for-all offering.
It's by his blood, Hebrews 10, that
we're able to enter in. Unlike in the
old when only one priest once a year
could enter into the presence of God.
Hebrews 10:1 19-20. We're going to get
into that next week as well.
But if there was no blood transferred to
heaven to then be transferred to Satan,
then their scapegoat claims also fall
with it. So, I'm not sure what he
thought he presented. That is a
challenge for my position thus far.
So now we need to go back and we need to
say, okay, check this out. By the way,
one more verse, then we're going to then
we're going to get then we're going to
get into the challenge, y'all. So, so
John chapter 19,
this title then read many of the Jews,
for the place where Jesus was crucified
was nigh to the city and was written in
Hebrew, Greek, and Latin. So, let me
break this nigh down for a moment.
This nigh to the city represents outside
the camp. So, so the nigh to the city
would would be the parallel to outside
the camp. Now remember,
the scapegoat is taken out into a
desolate place where there are no
inhabitants. But the Lord's goat, the
body, was removed just outside the camp,
nigh to the city. Jesus died right
outside the gates of Jerusalem.
H
notice that the scapegoat is not taken,
it doesn't use the term without the
camp. It uses the term into the
wilderness, a desolate place.
All right. So clearly you can see how
Ivor has no concept of Jesus being a
fulfillment of all of the laws,
sacrifices, and offerings in one.
The Adventist pretext of assuming the
scapegoat is Satan keeps him from being
able to see that this isn't a problem
whatsoever for Christians.
This is just a long form version of
begging the question. He is assuming
what he has not demonstrated.
I want to remind everyone, it has not
been demonstrated that the law said sin
offerings every single time, no matter
what, no questions asked, can only
include one animal.
Remember, his initial claim was to
refute that Leviticus 16:5 is saying
that both goats functioned as a singular
sin offering.
He then claimed three premises that were
all flawed like I showed. Then went on
to say the scapegoat wasn't stricken and
bruised for our iniquities yet ignored
that Isaiah also says sin was laid on
him
which was exclusive to the scapegoat.
And we haven't even gotten into
Leviticus 16:10 which says the scapegoat
had atonement made on it and the
horrendous presentation the SDA church
tries to put forth to justify Satan
having atonement made over him for
sinners. Aside from looking at what the
footnotes said in the fundamental
beliefs book just so you could see it,
we could do a whole night on that and
the problems with that. But now he
appeals to John 19:20 to say Jesus isn't
the scapegoat because the scapegoat was
taken into the wilderness and Jesus
wasn't. He was taken outside the camp.
Yes. And Ivor
utilizing your own standard of
argumentation.
I already showed how Jesus can't be the
Lord's goat then either because the
bodies of the animals taken outside the
camp were literally burned and Jesus
wasn't.
If you're going to do this hyper literal
one to one and miss the forest for the
trees, you end up proving too much.
It's like at this point you may as well
use the argument that well Jesus isn't a
goat.
The scapegoat was a goat but Jesus isn't
a goat. It's like
Notice the problem, folks. Again, if
he's going to utilize this
hyperliteralism and say Jesus wasn't
literally taken into the wilderness, but
the scapegoat was, therefore Jesus can't
be the scapegoat.
Then to be consistent, he has to also
say Jesus's body wasn't literally burned
outside the camp,
yet the Lord's goat was. Therefore,
Jesus can't be the Lord's goat either.
This is inconsistent and bad
argumentation.
Do not fall for their abuses of typology
like this. Typology is a picture for you
of a particular point, dimension, or
aspect of a greater reality. It's not an
exhaustive parallel for every single
minute thing.
such such that because Jesus wasn't
literally taken out into the wilderness,
he can't be the scapegoat. No, the
wilderness simply showed Israel that
their sin was gone into a desolate
place. Gone. Removed.
We're still waiting on anything that is
problematic for the Christian position.
Oh, sorry. Got to find my place here
again. I accidentally clicked off.
Okay.
Okay, let's go back to the screen.
Jesus, 1 Peter chapter 2:24, the Bible
says of Jesus, who in his own self bear
our sins in his own body on the tree,
outside the gap, outside the gates of
Jerusalem. He bare our sins. That's what
the Lord's goat did on the day of
atonement. But we're not going to get
into that yet. I just want you to see
that when that body was burned outside
the gates and Paul says, "Hey, the
body's burned outside the gates is a
symbol of Jesus who died outside the
gates." What did Jesus do outside the
gates on the cross? He bear our sins.
All right.
Nope. You're wrong, Ivor. You're wrong.
Like I said and showed earlier,
Leviticus 16 never says that sin was
placed on the Lord's goat and then
transferred to the scapegoat by means of
blood.
And I showed earlier Adam Clark, who
Ivor tried to cite to support his claims
regarding all sin offerings having to be
killed. He said this same thing.
The priest laid hands upon the scapegoat
and the sins were then placed on it. The
text does not say the sins were placed
on the Lord's goat first and then
transferred. They were exclusively
placed on the scapegoat, which is
another reason that it points to Jesus.
So, 1 Peter 2:24 backfires on the SDA
position and proves my position
in conjunction with understanding this
text in light of what was explained in
Hebrews 9, specifically verse 26.
Like the Levitical priest who had to put
sin away before he could enter into the
presence of God. So too Jesus after
having sin placed on him such that he
was like the fallen earthly sinladen
priest had to put sin away before he
could enter back into the presence of
God.
That was part of the work of the
suffering servant. And Hebrews 9 plainly
says he did this at Calvary. Not that he
transferred them into heaven by means of
his blood to begin a second phase of the
atonement in 1844
to eventually then transfer sin once
again to Satan who will have atonement
made on it.
And I have to reiterate once again,
notice he says Hebrews says the body of
the sin offering was burned outside the
camp. Yet Jesus's body wasn't literally
burned outside the camp. So don't be
inconsistent, Ivor. If you're going to
claim Jesus only fulfills the stuff
that's an exact 100% onetoone parallel,
then Jesus can't even be the Lord's goat
since his body wasn't literally burned
outside the camp.
Now, he's going to finally get to what's
supposed to be the challenge. Pay very
close attention here. I think y'all are
following this. Now, we need to get to
the Day of Atonement. So, let's go to
the Day of Atonement. Let's go back to
the screen and uh we're about to wrap
this up, you guys. The Day of Atonement.
Here we go. Here goes the challenge.
Here goes the challenge. Okay,
so on the day of atonement, here's what
the Bible says about this Lord's goat.
And Aaron shall bring the goat upon
which the Lord's lot fell and offer him
for an for a sin offering. H
offer
him for a sin offering.
So that offering symbolizes that the
that the Lord's goat was to die. Okay.
So far that fits the definition of a sin
offering. And notice how it says you
shall offer him for a sin offering. Not
offer them for a sin offering as in both
goats, but offer him for a sin offering.
Let's keep reading verse 15. Then shall
the then shall he kill the goat of the
sin offering that is for the people and
bring his blood within the veil and do
with that blood as he did with the blood
of the bulock. Oh wow. There we go. We
look the sin offering was not only
killed but as we learned his blood was
taken into the tabernacle sprinkled upon
a mercy seat and before the mercy seat.
Okay. Is that it?
Uhoh.
So that proves it right folks. He
started with verse 9 which is after
verse five
which already told us that both goats
function as a single sin offering.
He made a big deal saying Leviticus 16:9
doesn't say them but him.
Singular. It only refers to to one goat.
Right. Yeah. After verse 5 already told
you that both goats were to be taken as
a pair for a singular sin offering.
Nothing about verse 9 is exclusive. Such
that now four verses later after verse
5, the sin offering only involves a
single goat. Now,
it's like, "Hey, Moses, tell Levi to
take a pair of goats from the
congregation for a single sin offering
and then cast lots over them to see
which one will be the sin offering.
Thanks, God."
Yeah. No, that's not what's going on
here. When you don't do hopscotch exesus
where you just pick and choose verses
and jump around, you see that the entire
process involves both goats as a set and
they both then function together as a
complete picture of various aspects.
Then he just jumped to verse 15 and
tried connecting it back to where he
referred to in Leviticus 4 and the
instructions for when the priest sinned
which he made universal instructions for
all sin offerings.
We already saw how this is refuted by
simply reading in the same chapter of
Levitic Leviticus 4. No, not all sin
offerings involve blood being taken into
the sanctuary. That's not a universal
rule.
But what Ivor failed to mention is
something taking place in the grammar of
Leviticus 16:5, specifically with the
phrase, "Sprinkle it upon the mercy
seat,"
or rather verse 15, 16:15, like you see
still on screen.
something that creates a serious problem
for their sanctuary salvation model. The
Greek word for propitiation has to do
with well, notice what it refers to.
Notice the usage.
Hill eststerion propitiation.
A sin offering by which the wrath of the
deity shall be appeased. a means of
propitiation or b the covering of the
ark which was sprinkled with the atoning
blood on the day of atonement. And then
notice under the section word studies
the place of propitiation the lid of the
golden ark the mercy seat where the
blood of a vicarious lamb appeased God's
wrath on sin.
So what Leviticus 16:15 is referring to
is propitiation.
Remember what it said.
Then he shall kill the goat of the sin
offering that is for the people and
bring its blood into the veil and do
with its blood as he did with the blood
of the bull sprinkling it over the mercy
seat and in front of the mercy seat.
So the question becomes
when was propitiation made?
Well thankfully scripture tells us. I
feel like we look at Romans 3 every week
but here we are again.
But now the righteousness of God has
been manifested apart from the law.
Although the law and the prophets bear
witness to it, the righteousness of God
through faith in Jesus Christ for all
who believe. For there's no distinction.
For all have sinned and fall short of
the glory of God and are justified by
his grace as a gift through the
redemption that is in Christ Jesus, whom
God put forward as a propitiation by his
blood
to be received by faith. This was to
show God's righteousness because in his
divine forbearance he had passed over
former sins. It was to show his
righteousness at the present time so
that he might be just and the justifier
of the one who has faith in Jesus.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
So God the Holy Spirit tells us that
propitiation took place at Calvary when
Jesus was put forth. What is pictured in
the Levitical Day of Atonement,
specifically Leviticus 16:15, is at the
cross.
Christ's sacrifice at Calvary was the
true antitypical propitiation that the
earthly sanctuary service foreshadowed.
Folks, this is all we, you know, we've
looked at all of this stuff before.
Again, Hebrews 2:14-17, Matthew Henry
referenced this earlier,
who Ivor also cited from.
Since therefore the children share in
flesh and blood, he himself likewise
parttook of the same things, that
through death he might destroy the one
who has the power of death, that is the
devil, and deliver all those who through
fear of death were subject to lifelong
slavery. For surely it is not angels
that he helps, but he helps the
offspring of Abraham. Therefore, he had
to be made like his brothers in every
respect so that he might become a
merciful and faithful high priest in the
service of God to make propitiation for
the sins of the people.
Thus, the reading of God's holy word.
So in light of what we read in Romans 3,
propitiation taking place when Jesus was
put forth at Calvary.
Here the author is explaining how Jesus
didn't come to save angels but humans
which shouldn't be shocking that he is
called our brother
because he added unto himself human
nature.
But he had to take on a human nature in
our likeness so that he could what?
be a faithful and merciful high priest
for his brothers and make propitiation
for the sins of his people.
Again, Romans 3 said this took place at
Calvary when he was put forth. And here
we see he functioned as a priest in
doing so, just like the law required.
The day of atonement sacrifice had to be
put forth by who?
The high priest.
which further disproves their scapegoat
teaching because the investigative
judgment is necessary for their
scapegoat theology and their belief on
the investigative judgment says Jesus
wasn't uh Jesus was inaugurated as a
priest at his ascension.
Yeah, that's after Calvary.
Notice what even Adventist scholarship
recognizes.
This is from a paper titled
substitutionary atonement
by an Adventist scholar who is an
Adventist professor.
Quote,
"Caporet was rendered in the Septuagent
as hilsterion,
a term from the same root as hiliscomi,
to make gracious, to plate.
The same root appears in the uh
Septuagent's translation of kipper as
exaliscomi
and helosmos
often in sacrificial context. You'll
have to ignore my irraspian
pronunciation of the uh Greek and the
Hebrew.
In the New Testament, Helasmos
propitiation or expeation appears in the
phrase propitiation for our sins in 1
John 2:2 and 4:10. And in the case of
most abstract nouns, those words ending
in meant or shun,
atonement, expeation, and reconciliation
may designate the atoning reconciling
action itself or its effects, meaning
consequences.
Also, when pointing to the action
itself, they may express a function or
more concretely, the means by which the
function is performed. All these
possible uses of the term the terms may
be exemplified in biblical passages.
Close quote.
So quickly before moving forward, notice
the correlation between atonement and
expation which is even recognized by SDA
scholarship.
The Bible tells us that propitiation
happened at Calvary. It's not happening
up in a building in heaven now in a long
drawn out process. But that doesn't stop
them from trying to make it so because
of course he continues to try and make
this compatible with their sanctuary
model.
Quote, "Though Jesus did act as our high
priest by offering sacrifice, he did so
by the sacrifice of himself through whom
we have now received reconciliation."
Romans 5:11. Jewish and Gentile sinners
are equally justified by faith through
the grace of God who set forth Christ as
a propitiation or sacrifice of
atonement. Hill eststerion equals
caparet. Romans 3:25.
Hill eststerion is the term which in the
earthly sanctuary designated the ark
cover, the mercy seat. Hebrews 9:5. This
represented the throne of God as
intimated by images of cherubim which
were integral to the artifact of one
piece with it. Exodus 37 uh 377 and 8.
The ark cover was the place of
revelation
where the Lord would meet Moses and
speak to him and where the cloud of
God's glorious shakina presence
appeared. Leviticus 16:2.
Towards this artifact, the Yam Kapour
ritual was addressed. Leviticus 16 1-16.
So the Caparet by taking uh by itself
came to connotate the work of atonement.
The New Testament is well aware that as
prefigured in the mercy seat in Christ
dwells all the fullness of the Godhead
bodily being the image of the invisible
God and that God has spoken to us
through him. But he is hilsterion not
primarily as the sight of God's
indwelling or revelation but
fundamentally because he is the
propitiation hilosmos experation itself
1 John 2:2 and 4:10 this was a
propitiation by his blood Romans 3:25 in
atonement by blood sacrifice the blood
of his cross
quote
folks this is what I mean by there are
people in this movement that are smart
They're not all dumb.
You know, I get we get people that ask
us, you know, are are how could smart
people fall for this? Because folks,
there are smart people all over the
place that believe all sorts of errors.
Don't fall for the lie that all people
in this movement are are stupid people.
They're not. It's why we're trying to
get engagements with some of these
individuals, but they don't like
engaging that way. They'd rather stay in
their theological ivory towers and
whatever. That's on them. But
nevertheless, what he put forth here is
spoton. Aside from the misdefining of
words in order to uphold the great
controversy worldview, which creates
inconsistencies, he doesn't get into any
of those because again, what they mean
by the word atonement is the
investigative judgment.
We've looked at that, I don't know how
many times from scholarly sources.
This is from a section of this paper
where he's trying to explain how
propitiation fits within their sanctuary
model.
He started off by saying Jesus did act
as our high priest by offering himself.
Well, in their sanctuary model, they
claim he was inaugurated to be a priest
at his ascension.
The word inaugurated literally means to
begin or start.
Notice, just so you can see, folks,
there is a sanctuary in heaven, the true
tabernacle that the Lord set up and not
humans. In it, Christ ministers on our
behalf, making available to believers
the benefits of his atoning sacrifice
offered once for all on the cross. At
his ascension, he was inaugurated as our
great high priest and began his
intercessory ministry, which was
typified by the work of the high priest
in the holy place of the earthly
sanctuary.
So he was already a priest on earth and
then as at his ascension he was
inaugurated to be a high priest or a
priest again in some different manner.
It's like that's the only way to make
sense of this. No. Hebrews 21:17 says
that he functioned as a high priest when
propitiation was made. That was at the
cross. So they can't try and be like
well it says great high priest on earth.
He was a priest but his his inauguration
as the great high priest was at his
ascension. No.
Nevertheless, that Adventist scholar
recognizes what I showed you about the
Greek word hill eststerion as it
pertains to Romans 3. He recognizes its
connection to the mercy seat and what
took place there.
When that happened, it wasn't almost
2,000 years into the future that the
work then continued, which is what their
position has to say. Catch that because
Romans 3 says propitiation occurred when
Jesus was put forth as a sacrifice. That
was at Calvary. He recognizes that the
New Testament uses this term in such a
way that also means Jesus expedates sin
when propitiation is made.
when the SDA position is is what they're
trying to put forth specifically this
scholar's paper is that propitiation
includes both the sacrifice taking place
and the point at which the work is
actually applied to the sinner.
Therefore, that's supposed to justify
their sanctuary teaching because they
claim the atoning sacrifice happened at
Calvary. But the application of that
work take takes place in the heavenly
sanctuary uh when a person comes to the
advent Jesus
and both of those things are atonement
but only one happened at Calvary. That's
essentially what he's trying to put
forth. And like I said, this is why
understanding redemption accomplished
versus redemption applied is so
important. And it's why I'm going to be
putting a presentation together on that
subject because what he is arguing here
is very close to the truth. But then
there's a slight twist to try and Trojan
horse in their entire entire novel
framework.
No, the atonement was accomplished in
full at Calvary.
Jesus was inaugurated as a king at his
ascension to take his throne to rule and
reign over all of the cosmos after
accomplishing the redemption of all
things, redeeming the creation that fell
and making it new.
The benefits of this are indeed applied
at the point of a person truly believing
and being regenerated. But that's not
atonement.
The application of redemption is not
Atonement is when blood is shed. There's
blood shed when atonement occurs.
And by the way,
when I came across this paper not too
long ago,
for all the Adventists that have been
telling me the new creation's not
biblical, show me that in the Bible.
Same scholar in that same paper. Quote,
as mentioned before, reconciliation is
presented in the New Testament in 2
Corinthians 5:18 and 19. Here, God has
reconciled us to himself through Jesus
Christ and has given us the ministry of
reconciliation or committed to us the
word of reconciliation.
Such a word not only proclaims that God
was in Christ reconciling the world to
himself, when he made him who had no sin
to be a sin offering for us, so that in
him we might become the righteousness of
God. But it also announces that this act
of God has inaugurated a new creation.
One in which those who are in Christ
have already entered.
But that will not be fully realized
until the escaton. Revelation 21:1. This
is the final effect of the atoning work
which involves a process described in
the Bible with sanctuary language.
[Applause]
the exact thing that I've said I don't
even know how many times in front of
this microphone
except for that last sentence
and this is how SDA theology will
scramble your brain theologically. This
paper by this scholar is very close to
the truth. Very, very close. But he is
trying to filter all of this through a
lens to support their sanctuary model.
He recognizes that Jesus inaugurated a
new creation by virtue of his death,
burial, and resurrection. And he cites 2
Corinthians 5 to support his claim,
which is exactly where you have heard me
point to this on I don't know how many
occasions.
And the fact that the new creation is
here presently proves that the atonement
is finished.
The application of its benefits being
made in full, for example, like being
resurrected, having glorification
applied, etc. That stuff isn't
atonement. That's not atonement
happening.
Again, there is bloodshed when atonement
occurs.
All of this to say, Ivor, you you
shouldn't just breeze over these verses,
making assertions without seeing the
bigger picture. I mean, there is a lot
more going on here than just rattling
off a couple proof texts and thinking
you have some anvil that can wear out
any hammer in doing so.
That everything. No, we got another
verse here. Leviticus 16:18.
And he shall go out unto the altar that
is before the Lord, and make an
atonement for it, and shall take of the
blood of the bulock, and of the blood of
the goat,
and put it upon the horns of the altar
round about. Now notice verse 27.
And the bulock for the sin offering, and
the goats for the sin offering. Is that
what the text says?
Does the text say the goats for the sin
offering? If there were to be two goats
for the sin offering, why does the text
say the goat for the sin offering? Why
does it not say the goats for the sin
offering?
The goat for the sin offering whose
blood was brought in to make an
atonement in the holy place.
Let's go back to this. Can y'all see it?
shall one carry forth without the camp,
and they shall burn in their fire the
skins and their flesh and their dung.
So, here's what I want y'all to see,
y'all. Number one,
the goat for the sin offering, the
Lord's goat, was killed. Number two, its
blood was used. And number three, its
dead body was taken outside the camp.
Just as we read, hey, that's what a sin
offering is.
That's what a sin offering is.
Yeah. Except it's already been shown
that your three rules or premises were
all flawed and false on multiple fronts.
I've lost track of how many errors and
fallacies I've highlighted tonight. But
he asked why Leviticus 16:27 doesn't say
goats plural, but only goat singular.
Because Ivor, you're reading from a
portion of the instructions where it's
talking about the Lord's goat, which is
a part of the singular sin offering.
This is after the authors already told
you in verse 5 that both goats were for
a singular sin offering.
It makes me wonder if he actually
understands the position he's
criticizing at a granular level.
Like it only mentions one goat there
because it's talking about one goat.
That doesn't say that the sin offering
though is only the one goat.
I don't know why he thinks this is some
brain buster.
Nothing that he has put forth proves
that both goats aren't involved in one
singular sin offering.
None of the verses that he has read
anywhere in the Bible prove that all sin
offerings universally can only include
one animal.
The point is that both goats paint a
picture of the atonement. Part of
atonement includes the scapegoat which
took place uh uh you know which took the
sin away from the people as a visible
sign to their eyes. The sin offering was
a part of accomplishing atonement and
Leviticus 16:10 already told you that
the scapegoat was involved in the
atonement. And we already saw where the
SDA church blasphemously tries to
explain how Satan can be a part of the
atonement in an accommodated sense. But
the answer is simple. It doesn't say the
goats plural because you're reading from
a portion of the instructions that have
to do with the goat that was sacrificed,
not the scapegoat.
And the verse doesn't say the Lord's
goat is a singular sin offering to the
exclusion of the scapegoat. It's not an
exclusionary statement.
This is not sound biblical exesus, my
friends.
There is a reason he isn't reading
through the chapter verse by verse or
even attempting any sort of contextual
pretext.
All right. Now, he's going to get into
the SDA appeals and claims to the term
Azazil. Pay very close attention.
Well, let's talk about Aazel. Let's go
to the screen. Aazel. And as you all
learned in my previous presentations,
Aazel meaning the goat of departure,
meaning the goat of fa, the goat who
fails, who who who
witches and and and and and new wagers
and and demon worshippers all say
without fail Aazelle represents Satan
who Jews say Aazelle represents the a
goat of demons.
Let's see what happened to this Aazelle.
Leviticus 16:21.
And Aaron shall lay both his hands upon
the head of the live goat, and confess
over him all the iniquities of the
children of Israel, and all their
transgressions, and all their sins,
putting them on the head of the goat,
and shall send him away by the hand of a
fit man into the wilderness. And the
goat shall bear upon him all their
iniquities unto a land not inhabited.
and he shall let the goat go in the
wilderness.
Okay, y'all. Let's come back. Let's come
back.
So, here is the problem. Here is the
problem.
In fact, go back to the screen. I need
y'all to see the problem on the screen.
The scapegoat is not killed.
The scapegoat sheds no blood.
The dead body of the scapegoat is not
taken without the camp. The living body
of the scape of the scapegoat is taken
out into a desolate place.
In other words, the scapegoat does not
fit the requirement of the sin offering
and therefore
it is not part
of a single sacrifice.
Let me say it again. And we're going to
issue the challenge right now. We're
going to issue the challenge right now.
So here, let me say it again.
If the Lord's goat
takes care of both
the death of Christ and the removal of
sin by having its body taken outside the
camp, which Hebrews says this is the
fulfillment in Christ,
the sins placed on him through his
death, his body taken outside the camp
signifies the removal of sin. So if all
that is done in one goat, then my
question is what is this other goat for?
What is the purpose of the scapegoat?
What does the live goat do?
Are we using him to to symbolize the
same thing that the sca that the living
go that the that the Lord's goat just
did?
Why would the Lord do that?
Did Jesus die outside the gates of the
camp or was he sent into the wilderness
as a living goal?
[Music]
Here's a challenge.
Y'all got 24 hours
from hearing this this this this
presentation.
So, put it I'll put it up on the screen.
Since the death
since the death
and expeation of sin
is typified in one sacrifice
as is demonstrated in the daily services
of the sin offering. Do y'all see this
on the screen?
Okay, there we go.
Since the death and expeation of sin is
typified in one sacrifice, one symbol,
as is demonstrated in the daily services
of the sin offering, a second goat would
not have been needed to typify what was
already typified in the Lord's goat,
namely that it died for sin and bore
away our sins.
Since the goat for Aazel does not fit
the description of a sin offering, what
then was the purpose of the goat for
Aazel?
Y'all got it?
Do y'all have the Do y'all get the
challenge?
Is the Bible using the Lord's goat and
the scapegoat
to do the exact same thing?
No. Because the Lord's goat isn't
picturing both the penalty for sin being
paid and expeation. All of your
fundamental premises are flawed as I
have demonstrated. The scapegoat
functions like I and other Christians
have been saying for a long time.
It pictured sin being taken away and
nothing that you have presented proved
this to be false because your attempts
to prove what what you needed regarding
the Lord's goat functioning as both the
penalty for sin and expeation was badly
flawed.
Notice at the beginning of the clip he
said witches, newagers, and demon
worshippers all say Aazil represents
Satan. So a bunch of pagans all say
Aazil is Satan. So that proves Aazil is
Satan.
He said, 'The Jews believe it represents
a demon. Oh, you mean the same Jews that
don't believe Jesus was the Lord's goat.
Okay.
It's always interesting the context in
which Adventists agree with pagans or
Roman Catholics, etc. Conveniently, it's
whenever the party they fundamentally
disagree with agrees with them on
something they need for their system to
work.
The party they disagree with knows what
they're talking about in those
instances, but only on the thing that
they need affirmation for.
It doesn't matter if all the world's
highest IQ individuals agree that Azil
is Satan. What matters is the Hebrew
grammar. And for anyone that does a deep
dive on this subject, they will see that
the SDA position is at the bottom of the
scholarly opinions because it requires
support from pagan and pseudapigful
works such as the book of Enoch.
Pseudapigal works, folks, is just
writings that people don't know who the
author actually was.
When I debated this with an Adventist
pastor, I dug into this as thoroughly as
I was able, which was a pretty decent
amount. Ivor states his position like
it's just a matter of fact when the
actual facts are this is a grammar issue
and his side's position is one of the
four main ones and it's at the bottom of
the pile because it primarily is
supported through tradition whether it
be from pagans or Jewish folklore. But
notice for example
what the Jewish virtual library says on
this under the word aazil.
Quote the exact meaning of oazil was a
point of dispute already in the times of
talmudic sages.
That's just referring to the the
interpreters of of the old testament.
That's what the talmutic sages were.
Some held that it is in the name uh it
is the name of a place to which the goat
was sent. While others believed that it
was the name of some power.
According to the first opinion, the word
aazil is a parallel to a land which is
cut off. Leviticus 16:22 meaning
according to the rabbitic interpretation
an area of rocks and cliffs i.e. it was
inaccessible.
The word Azil is also interpreted as
meaning strong and hard as though it
were written namely hardest of the
mountains
as can be seen in the Tarums which is
what it then lists there. The Targums
are essentially that same thing. They
are if I remember correctly Aramaic
commentaries on Old Testament
scriptures. So you can see they're in
Yoma and and Tarum Jonathan etc.
It does appear, however, that this is an
attempt to reconcile the meaning of the
word Aazil with the actual usage in the
time of the second temple, namely to
bring the goat to a cliff and to push it
over. The interpretation does not quite
fit the written form of the word.
Close quote.
momentarily.
Notice even in the days of the Talmudic
sages, which like I said, they were
Jewish rabbis that lived from around 250
BC to 6 somewhere around 600 AD. There
was dispute over this word. Some
believed that it was the name of a
place. Others believed it was the name
of a power, not the devil specifically,
but a power. It continues,
"The second opinion which sees Azil as a
supernatural power also treats the word
as though it were written, this opinion
is based on Leviticus 16:8. One lot for
the Lord and the other lot for Aazil.
I.e. just as the first goat is set aside
for the Lord, so the second is set aside
for Aazil. Aazil being a parallel to the
Lord,
God gets a burnt offering while Aazil
gets a sin offering. This view is
reinforced by the widespread belief that
the wilderness was the habitat of
demons.
The demonic identification would
indicate that the original purpose of
the ritual was to get rid of the evil by
banishing it to its original source.
Close quote.
This is the idea that the SDA position
tries to seek accordance with. And there
are a couple of others. One being that
Azazil represents a function, the goat
of escape. That's why modern
translations will translate it as
scapegoat versus Azazil.
The point being, this isn't just a
matter of fact as he presents it. We've
already refuted basically everything he
has said up to this point and shown why
it's faulty on multiple accounts.
Now, if the argument hinges on this,
despite all of that, it hinges upon
ambiguity where there's been
long-standing debate over what exactly
the term Aazil means.
But then once again, we heard the
argumentative claim that the scapegoat
isn't killed. Yeah, we know that isn't
the argument. And even in the
introduction,
we looked at El Michael Morales's Who
Shall Ascend the Mountain of the Lord
where he states this specifically. It
wasn't a standard,
but he also recognized it wasn't the
general way that a sin offering was
offered. This was a unique one.
And we still have yet to see anything
that proves exhaustively that no sin
offering could include two animals and
only one of them dies.
I've already refuted his requirements
for the sin offering claims, so I'm not
going to repeat myself.
Ivor, you need to demonstrate that
Leviticus 16:5 doesn't say what it says.
That's the challenge for you.
But then we finally heard the formal
issue of the challenge. If all those
things are as he said up to the point,
if all the things he said up to that
point are true, which he believes he
demonstrated that the Lord's goat alone
pays the penalty for sin and removes it
outside the camp, then what is the other
goat for?
Yes. and Ivor, I already demonstrated
all three of your premises are flawed,
which means the question is nullified.
I already showed that none of the texts
that you provided state that all sin
offerings universally can only include
one animal. I already showed where you
cited from Leviticus 4 and the
requirements for it being the priest
sinning and then you made universal
application of that to all sin offerings
that the blood had to be taken into the
sanctuary which is false because in the
same chapter there are sin offerings
that don't involve taking blood into the
sanctuary. I already showed that the
sins were never placed on the Lord's
goat, only the scapegoat. And how first
Peter 2:24 and Isaiah 53 backfire on
your position. In conjunction with that,
I already showed how Hebrews 9:26 says
that Jesus put sin away at the cross,
just like the Levitical priest had to
put sin away before he could enter into
God's presence. So too, Jesus, after
having the sins of his people placed
upon him on the cross, also had to put
that sin away before he entered back
into the presence of God as the God man.
And that putting away wasn't a
transference to heaven, folks. It was an
actual removal.
I already showed that you guys can't
have Jesus removing the sin by virtue of
being taken outside the camp because you
guys don't even teach that sin has been
put away today in 2024.
It's currently in the process, which is
what the investigative judgment is
supposedly for. And it will be expedated
by Satan when it's transferred to him at
the close of the investigative judgment.
Which means you can't believe sin was
expedated when Jesus was taken outside
the camp. I already showed how that was
done in Leviticus 16:15. Propitiation
took place at the cross, which the ex
which the SDA church has taken place
over a long drawn out span of time
starting in 1844, which is a you know a
massive gap from when the blood was shed
to when the actual removal process would
start.
And I could, as a bonus, have also shown
how Hebrews 9:22 cites Leviticus 17:11,
which says that without the shedding of
blood, there's no uh remission or
removal of sins, and that Jesus only
shed his blood one time. Yet, you guys
say sins are being removed starting in
1844, but Jesus isn't up in heaven
shedding his blood. That happened 2,000
years ago at Calvary, and only at
Calvary. But I will save an in-depth
analysis to that point for next week.
Like I said, when we do our first total
biblical decimation episode, we won't be
looking at any video, by the way, folks.
We will just be going through a whole
boatload of scripture. The first one is
going to be focused on the sanctuary and
the investigative judgment.
The living goat didn't symbolize both
things like he claimed because his claim
is built on faulty premises.
He goes on to claim that same thing that
Adventist scholarship does like we've
seen before that the scapegoat
represented responsibility for sin
despite the fact that the text does not
say this or even mention anything close
to the idea that the scapegoat
represented responsibility.
Remember folks, this whole thing was
started out by him taking umbrage with
Leviticus 16:5, which plainly says two
goats were to be taken for a single sin
offering.
They were both taken from the
congregation. Both had to be blemish
free. Both had to be presented before
the tent of the Lord. Both had to have
lots cast over them. They are a set.
Nothing he presented proved that they
aren't. All that was demonstrated is
that Adventist theology is a mess.
This challenge was like the bunny slopes
at the, you know, at the ski resort.
Folks, it's important to understand that
Adventists have been making the same
arguments for 180 years.
Nothing he said here is unique or
problematic except to their own
position.
Folks, Christians have been studying
scripture for a long time,
thousands of years.
Christians have been pondering and
studying what scripture says about the
atonement for 2,000 years.
None of what he presented was fresh,
new, or challenging.
And since he thinks it was, it shows he
doesn't actually understand what he
criticizes.
I I appreciate him playing clips from
this platform before he got into his
talk to try and steal man the position,
but he needs to listen more closely. He
was correct in the generals, but he
doesn't understand the specifics.
You know, Adventists can say what they
want about me in this platform, but I
stand by my homework all day, any day.
Does that mean I'm never wrong? Of
course not.
But one thing I can say is I've studied
and learned the SDA system enough to be
able to analyze it at an advanced level.
I sat and listened to Adventists teach
for two decades.
I've also listened to Christians teach
now for over a decade.
I'm able to analyze and put my great
controversy worldview back on
what I presented tonight is not unique
to me. I didn't originate this stuff.
I'm simply a messenger. I'm a servant of
Christ. I want to be a service to the
body of Christ as best I best I can be.
So, Ivor, nice swing, but no contact.
Got to study up better and get outside
of the SDA programming. Start basing
your arguments off of entire sections of
scripture where you capture entire
thoughts and what's going on
contextually,
not this hopscotch exesus all over the
Bible in small little sound bites with
preconceived beliefs and proof texts
that use certain words to then try and
make all sorts of assertions based on
those words.
All that is is word association fallacy.
Words mean what they mean in the context
in which they are used.
You know, a perfect example of this is
where Jesus describes the kingdom of
heaven. Like a little levan that a woman
kneads into dough. Yet in other places,
levaven is described as sin
means words don't have a universal
meaning across the board. They have a
semantic range. It depends the context
in which they're being used in.
And we unfortunately did not hear any
breakdown of of that from him. But
credit where credit's due. Regardless of
what you might think about him as an
individual, he at least attempted to
build and present a deductive argument,
albeit one that's been put forth by SDA
theologians for 180 years and presents
zero problems for the Christian
position.
But thanks for being here, folks.
Hopefully, this was beneficial for you.
May Christ richly bless you in the grace
and peace won by Jesus Christ and his
vicarious death on the cross for
sinners. Hallelujah. Amen. Marinatha
come Lord Jesus.
[Music]